No. Oh Shit. Yeah.
Hello Ladies and gentlemen, the
Joe Rogan experience by, Oh, I,
just to tell you how we do this,
we do these two little commercials
before we actually do the podcast,
but they're very informal and
you could jump in at anytime.
So if you got something side, don't
hold your time. I don't hear him. Yeah,
no, no, I don't hear him on a microphone.
Did you hear me now? There we go.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that is the voice of the Great Tom.
We chunk the Joe Rogan experience podcast
is brought to you by the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link for the flashlight
and enter the code name Rogan.
You will save yourself 15% off,
one of the most ridiculous things you
could ever bring up in a conversation.
But an excellent sex tool and
excellent masturbation device.
And the number one sex toy from mine were
also brought to you by [inaudible] Dot
Com that's o.
N n I t.
Makers have such delicious
supplements is Alpha brain,
new mood, uh, shroom tech,
sport and trim, tech,
immune Alpha brain being my favorite
and the most controversial, what it is,
is it nootropic. And, uh, if you're
interested in any of these things,
I suggest you Google it first. First
and foremost. Find out what they are.
They're essentially vitamins that
enhance your brain's ability to function,
enhances your,
your brain's ability to produce
neurotransmitters and it makes your brain
operate more smoothly.
There have been a bunch of different
tests on various nootropics. Uh,
we are working on doing a clinical trial,
a,
I guess they call it a double blind
placebo clinical trial with Alpha brain.
As soon as we're set on our formula.
And we should be doing that shortly.
And what it does is when any of these
things do is they just enhance your body's
health and function.
And we know that all these
various nutrients have been
very effective on helping
people. People with
Alzheimer's, for instance,
if taken some of these nutrients
and show an improvement on them,
just stands to reason that there are
vitamins and nutrients that that aid your
body's function.
And if you take him it would work better.
And that's what these are all about.
If you're interested at all,
please go to [inaudible]
dot com and check it out.
We also just recently got in the kettle
bells and I've talked about this in the
podcast before.
If there's a,
there's the one workout that I
could do for the rest of my life.
It would be kettlebells cause I think
it's a, it's an awesome workout that's,
it translates directly intellectual life
until like your ability to move shit
and your ability to use your body. It's
a, it's a health exercise, you know,
because like a lot of
bodybuilding type shit,
like can you start doing bench
presses and curls and stuff.
I mean it can make you look
great and get big ass arms,
but the reality is your body
doesn't really work like that.
You're not supposed to
like isolate things.
I mean you can't if you
want them to get bigger,
but the best thing to do for
athletic performance is to
use your body as a whole.
That's why when you see like MMA
fighters training on, on television,
very rarely will you see
them do isolation exercises.
Usually it's throwing sandbags or hitting
hammers into a car tires or you know,
it's a, it's climbing ropes.
It's throwing ropes around,
doing battle ropes, doing kettle bells,
doing, but like Olympic clean and jerks.
It's all about using your whole body.
If you see like an Olympic
clean press like that,
guys use an everything man. He's
using his legs, his arms, his back,
his traps.
I mean,
it's an incredible full body movement
and full body movements are the ones that
really get your body stronger for
like functional things. Like for me,
it's Jujitsu. For some people it's,
you know, anything that you like doing,
where physical strength comes into play,
kettlebells will enhance that.
It just makes your body stronger.
It's awesome and you can get a good
workout in 20 minutes. We have some,
um, instructionals that are available
at [inaudible] dot com but your,
there's a million different
videos on the Internet.
All of Steve Maxwell stuff is outstanding.
He is probably one of the best guys in
the world when it comes to Kettlebell
training and he has a bunch of DVDs that
are for sale and he's a great guy too.
So if you bought those
DVDs and helped him out,
it would be awesome cause he
is the best in the business.
And there's videos online.
You can watch youtube videos,
he's got demonstrations online,
he can do,
there's just plenty of workouts that you
could formulate together and you really
don't need to go to a gym.
We also sell these battle ropes
and those are those crazy things.
You see Brock Lesnar flopping
around and uh, some of those, uh,
workout things where he's preparing for
fights and a incredibly hard workout.
Whereas used to prepare for
fights. Yeah, I used to.
So I wonder if you translate that.
No. Oh yeah. I'm sure he does. Yeah.
I don't think he stopped and I don't
think he's done. I think you'll be back.
I think this basketball player,
I think who needed to heal up,
he needed to heal up. I have a feeling
he'll be back. He's too fucking good.
Too big, too much potential. He
could still do it. They have,
but you know what man, you, because
you didn't get over getting kickback.
That and that wouldn't quit me
for the two life. Well, some,
everybody's got a different
path in this life. Anyway,
go check all that shit@ana.com
for the supplements. Only.
Use the code name Rogan,
and you'll save yourself 10% off
the battle ropes in the kettlebells.
Seriously about as cheap as
you can sell them. Um, it's,
it's very difficult to make and ship
and hire people to move these fucking
things around. Essentially sending
cannon balls through the mail.
But for the supplements, you
can use the code, any Rogan,
and you save yourself 10% off.
Also in the supplements,
any first bottle of 30 pills, there's
a hundred percent money back guarantee.
You don't even need to return the
product. He just say, this stuff sucks.
This didn't work for me. I didn't
feel it. That's all you need to say.
You get your money back.
We're way more concerned with not having
people feel ripped off than we are with
making money. And on top of that, like I
said, I use them. I benefited from him.
I know Lorenzo Fertitta loves fucking
Alpha brain and stuff has spectacular.
I really enjoy it and we're so confident
that you're gonna enjoy it too.
That we offer 100% money back guarantee.
All right,
go to [inaudible] dot Com oh and that's
it. The Great Tommy Chong gets here,
ladies and gentlemen.
Oh thanks to
Alienware sponsored MMA fighters
to choose an Alienware shit.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
We just started using these laptops.
Tommy Chong with this Dalian logo.
I'm like a child. I liked little
alien heads. Udl stuff. Yeah.
I don't know if that's like
a stoner thing. What is that?
I shouldn't be over like little
aliens too. Overgrown kid.
Thank you very much for coming on the
show, man. Submit to me. This is huge.
When I was a kid, my parents introduced
me to a Cheech and Chong movies and,
and Cheech and Chong albums when I was,
I was a little kid.
My parents were hippies,
especially my stepdad.
My stepdad was a huge hippie and
he loved to Shit, man. And uh,
so for me to throw around. Yes. Yeah,
he is. How's he doing? He's doing great.
Does he ever come to the fights
and that? Oh No. He's never,
I think they've come to one. This is not
really into that. He's a real hippie,
peaceful guy. Yeah. Yeah.
I think he always felt,
it was really weird that I was obsessed
with martial arts and I was a kid.
I don't think he really liked it
that much, but he loved you, man.
Everyone's different.
Everyone's different. Yeah.
Maybe that's why I pushed the other way.
You know,
who really gets pissed off at the
Kettle Bell? The delivery man. Oh yeah.
It's fucking hard.
The people or the ups store,
they look at me when I get them in
the mail. Like what fucking really?
I didn't even,
I didn't sign up to workout this little
girls that work there and I'm so sorry.
And you know,
and these things are 70 fucking pounds,
70 pounds from where cannon pointed to
80 years old. They give you an heavier,
they give you, there's dudes out there
that use 120 pounds. I've seen him.
I I trained at a place where they
use kettle bells and this dude,
his name is Mike [inaudible]
and he's all Vegan too,
which is cool that he's able to put
on this much mass and be all Vegan.
It's all muscle though. Oh, he's an
animal. And he's got uh, one of the,
he's got some of the best DVDs
when it comes to like really like,
like heavy weight exercises.
He throws around some heavy
fucking kettlebells. Yeah.
Like you see him doing these crazy
exercises with like one 20 fives.
And that's really hard to do these things.
Well if you've never seen it before folks,
it's almost like you kind
of doing gymnastics almost.
It's like you're doing different
exercises like kettlebell up or
a Kettlebell is a ball like a cannon
ball with a handle. That's all it is.
Probably was. That's probably
where they got out. I'm sure.
Probably a handle and a, and they use
them right at the turn of the century.
Sandow the strongest man in the world.
He always pulls with this kettlebells.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
And it's funny how the whole body
building thing went full circle.
It started out, you know, back in the
Greek, uh, days and that, you know, they,
they use animals to work out with, you
know, they pick up a cow until you know,
a calf until it became a cow. Really?
Yeah. Yeah. I mean that's how they trained
bad for the Olympics to
anybody out that working
hard. Who was the first guy to figure it
out? Working hard makes you bigger. Oh,
it goes back to the cavemen.
They take it to that out.
Like cavemen did like push ups and
shit. Oh No, no, no. They did pushups.
Men, you know, like pushing an
animal or running their ass off. No,
it's fight or flight. You
know, the humans were,
we were prey when we were
first shown us on this earth.
We've always been praised and it's always
been either we fight or we run until
we figured out cities and cat. Damn.
Do we get ahead of the game, the city,
the city, as soon as we figured
out cities. Yeah. Well, you know,
as soon as he figured out that
agriculture agriculture first before that,
it was like tribes of people
going around seeing who had what.
And what's really crazy is that it's
kind of in dispute now. There's um,
there's a bunch of different,
uh,
scientists now that are pointing to
all these different sites that they've
located where they're saying like,
it's real possible that like people were
hunter and gatherers like way longer
ago than we think.
Sure.
There were cities and civilizations
in between, in between before 10,
15,000 years ago. And it probably
wouldn't, it probably went back.
It probably went back to it. Yeah.
Yeah. They've found out recently some,
some new spot. It's underwater.
That's a 8,500 years old.
Like Atlanta. He's just a village.
It's a village. That was underwater.
And they say that the,
you know,
the earth's sea levels have changed so
much that there's like probably like a
bunch of shit, like cities everywhere.
This is underwater. Yeah. And I was like,
we have like a weird view of the past.
It's like so piecemeal.
It's almost like there's too much stuff
to know and a lot of what most people
don't even want to know.
Yeah.
I get into some of those conversation
and especially my wife would do that.
Her eyes will glaze over.
Yeah.
A lot of people don't give a fuck
and those aren't looking for, oh,
excuse me for a minute.
And
it all interests me though. I mean,
I'm really like when I was in,
I was in Paris a few years ago and
it went to museum of antiquity beyond
antiquities where they had the cave
drawings and they had the tools made by
these so called cabinet.
Well,
the tools he made were made out of,
uh, this Brock to, it's like glass,
you know, I forget what
it's called, but anyway,
that you could do major surgeries with
them, they could to get him so sharp. Wow.
And, and the, and the way they formed him,
it wasn't healthloop time or you know,
you know,
cave that typical Flintstone image,
these tools were phenomenal.
You could put him today and cs,
I had these tools made,
especially by this named artists and
everybody would go, yeah, I believe that.
Wow.
Oh,
I don't know. Million, billion.
I mean really it goes back,
right.
I didn't even think they were
even humans a million years ago.
So it was just a long time ago.
We don't have to say million,
let's just say it right back to the,
to the beginning. Oh, well what
they found, what they found,
they found a rock that they would
sharpen the spirits with. Uh,
they were actually superior
as long spear tips and,
but they would get so sharp because they
were made up some kind of rock glass
thing.
Yeah, I know. I know. I don't
know what it's called. I don't
remember. But yeah, it's,
it's beautiful. They would chip them
and they would get them like literary,
Razor Sharp, razor sharp and, and
that's how they killed the, the bigger,
bigger animals. What a weird
thing of nature though. I mean,
somewhere along the line we must've been
strong enough to kill shit or should we
just,
did we just get stronger when we started
eating things and where we vegetarians
before that?
Well they, they found skulls
of people, ancient people.
And you can see the ones that were
eating, you know, with a big job.
Bones and the big,
there are meat eaters basically.
It is weird
that there are meat eaters
and vegetarians. It is a
weird thing about life,
like things like deer and cows. It's
kind of weird that they don't eat meat.
Like you could just walk right by them.
You don't ever have to worry about that.
But if they were meeting eaters,
you'd be fucked. Oh, you'll be fucked.
If a cow was a meat eater, could you
imagine if a cow was trying to eat you?
Cows are fucking huge,
big hippo mouths and they were
just looking to eat people.
We would have a real
fucking problem with cows.
It's weird how there's animals that eat
animals and in his animals that don't do
any animals any harm.
And you could basically just fuck them up.
And then the ones closest to
humans are the ones that are there.
The really fucked up. The chimps.
Yeah. Cause they're, they're both,
they'll lead meat and they'll eat
vegetables. They'll eat whatever,
whatever is there to eat, but they'll,
they'll, they'll find another chimp.
He looks hungry. He looks, he looks a
good list here. His ass apart. Yeah.
If they could do cannibalism, I believe
it. Tim Scare the shit out of me.
Yeah. It's about that kid
that got mailed it. Well,
he was attacked apparently that
sanctuaries for reintroducing
chimps to the wild.
They take chimps that were kidnapped and
forced to work in zoos and for pets and
experimented on it.
I may send essentially all champs are
kidnapped if we admit the chimps are
intelligent, right. They are. We, we know
they're intelligent. You know, they're,
they're, they're almost people. And yet
we just wheel out to kidnap him and,
and test shit on. Yeah. Yeah. Let's see
what happened to him with we do this tool,
it's kind of fucked when you
really think about it this way.
They get pissed off when
they get a chance, you know,
they get ruthless way of finding
out shit. You got to go. Wow.
Is that the only girl?
Well like the circus people?
Yeah. Ever. Ever, ever be
around circus people like Tamer.
I seen a metal lion tamer in Spain.
I guess it was what?
A cocky pitch. No, it was a guy who
was a guy and you could tell me about,
you could, you could, you could tell
that was a generational thing. You could,
you could tell who the lion tamer was.
There's a crowd of people,
you look at the guy with
the big claw marks across.
Oh no way. Big Claw marks.
Oh right. And Crosses. Woo.
So you go home and,
and you could see the land because the
most exciting part about the circus was
watching him on load and
load all the animals.
You control these big cats. Wow.
That's part of the Gig, you know,
just when you think you can trust him,
he had turned their back and come.
How many Siegfried and Roy to have to
happen for people wake the fuck up.
And everybody was like, oh, the tiger was
frightened by a feather and the crowd.
And so it grabbed him to drag him
to safety. Ah, I'm not buying that.
That thing's not scared of shit.
It's a fucking giant white tiger.
What are you talking about?
You really think it's scared of a
lady with a feather in our hat? Yeah.
Fuck out of here. There's a tiger
decided to just fuck that dude up.
And that's what they do.
You see the thing on television?
What was it about a Bengal
tiger in this guy was,
they had a little, uh, I was in Thailand,
I think was drawn elephants anyway.
And they were like,
one guy was a gatekeeper.
He had a bamboo pole and this they what?
They had this tiger and they watched
him and all of a sudden the tiger Bengal
tiger leaped over the elephant
and took one of the guys arms,
took photos,
his hands and the whoever was filming,
they can fill me. And, and, and
the, and then the commentators said,
uh,
the animal trainer wasn't hurt bad.
And you could see the guy
who was missing a hand.
He was like holding his
hand and screaming. Oh. And
the tiger was like up that,
that high. And then they, then
they, uh, they dissect it, you know,
visually the cat and showed you where,
why it could spring so high, why could
jump so high and, and it showed the tooth,
the teeth, and the reason the
cat could move the way it is,
the way it moves is that the
bones were not connected to the,
to the muscle tissue.
And muscle tissue was all separate
and there was no ligaments attached.
And so they could, so it's all
one mass of muscle. When that cat,
you don't have ligaments,
they showed the, the bones,
the bones aren't attached to
the, to the muscle. Oh Wow. Well,
I don't even know how the hell that
would work. How would that work? Well, I,
Lou would have, uh, how does it work
if the bond is not attach the muscle,
they just, it floats in
Phillips, it's free floating.
So the bone is just, just,
it's a ribcage. Ah, see,
see the mo most bones or are around us
to protect her.
You nerds are right know
the way we're structured.
But this Bengal tiger,
in order to make that leap,
it can't be attached to anything.
You know, the, the strength
would tear the ligaments Y,
Z and so, so instead of
it's a design, you know,
and so instead it's like free floating in,
in,
in amongst the rest of the
meat and everything else.
But it was interesting in,
in the razor collage that the
claws come out automatically,
like switchblade knives,
they come out and the razor sharp
razor sharp razor sharp people.
Amy,
you can't even wrap your head around this
in a house cat and then represent it's
a Bengal tiger with the,
with the fans is so when it,
when it gets to the
neck or something like,
like a big Godder baffled or
something, you know, it can do damage.
Oh my God.
But,
but it showed that tech cat
jumping up and it took the,
took the guy and the
guy's got a bamboo stick.
No bamboo stick. No hand.
Oh it was, it was awesome.
It's, it's pretty clear that those things
are put here to clean shit up. Those,
those things are put here to make sure
there's less things. The last big thing,
they're big things.
Everything on earth,
including cockroaches and
ants and everything is,
their whole mission is to
clean shit up. Yeah, it's true.
Isn't it funny how that is? It is
funny. It's like, it's all a big cycle.
Like mountain lions have to kill the
deers and here's eat the grass and yeah.
Yeah. And their food, their,
their, their survival for bears.
And it's just, we're, we're so
removed from that as human beings,
especially lately.
And you know,
this last portion of society's last
a hundred years or so worried to buy
anything in a grocery store like we've
so removed ourselves from that whole life
and death struggle for meat now meet.
It's just sort of become something he
just by like we've completely removed
ourselves from this primal equation
actually killing the animal.
Actually taking apart the animal.
The weird,
like really kind of delusional
about using all the animal. I mean,
how many people are, they eat meat
but they don't like hunting. I don't,
I don't like it makes him sick.
If they see a dead animal on the
road or something, they'll get,
they'll turn their stomach. It's
weird, man. That's, that's a delusion.
All sort of a weird state of mind.
That was the thing is the commissioning
the animals, you know when the,
when the eat the me too, you know, it's
not, they'll, they'll go in for the,
for the Oregon's right away.
Yeah. Isn't that cool? Yeah. And then
they will leave the rest to ride.
Well that's what they figure
out. Who's the Alpha Wolf? Hmm.
They'll eat the liver of the Alpha
Wolf gets eaten. Deliver. Yeah. Yeah.
There was this crazy, you never
see that documentary, Brian,
that dude to lift with walls.
The guy actually used to plant a kill
and put a liver there and then eat the
liver in front of the wall so that he
would be the one that was in control.
Oh yeah.
Did you ever dance with them?
I don't think it was the same type
of movie. I think he's in his car.
Yeah, it was crazy. And then, uh, he,
he had to go away to fix something.
There was some wolf,
he's a wolf expert and they were saying
Wolf invasion and this other area.
So you got to go to help somebody.
When we came back,
the other wolves that decided
he wasn't the Alpha anymore,
so then he had a beg for forgiveness
and he had to be a Beta and it was
terrifying man. No dude was whimpering
and whimpering and doing all this.
He knew lot of the moves in front of
this big fucking a wolf with its teeth
bared. It's acute. It was
so horrific. You think,
what would it be like to be that man
right now locked in a cage with a wolf who
doesn't want you to be the Alpha anymore
and especially, oh wolf. That brand,
they're so smart and you know,
the guy was just on is just working on
his wits, just trying to keep it together.
While that was going on, I must've
been, oh, he became a wall.
He obviously became a of, obviously you
did the right thing and he was going
put the Taylor's side turn around.
Amazing man. It was amazing.
He just tucked tail on that
wolf and the wolf accepted it.
It was so frightening to watch, man.
It was really a, it's a gripping thing.
You know people on this podcast,
the Twitter people go, man,
he told both fucking scary animals
too much. He said, I'm sorry folks.
I don't mean to have this
as a recurring theme.
This is just how I really fucking
think. Okay. They're scary.
That tiger that jumped on an elephant,
it's fucking horrified.
They're like avatar creatures,
but real acrobatic. I mean, yeah,
20 feet. 20 feet. Yeah. It's incredible.
It showed him spring and 20
feet and he went up. Boom.
It's funny to just name that
and gone.
It's so crazy that nature decided
to make something like that. It's,
it's really ridiculous.
It's like everybody else,
it's on a bicycle and all of a sudden
this is something that's on a corvette.
You know? It's like a, it's total
rip off. It's not fair at all.
Tiger Tiger's not fair at all.
The fact that we can exist in the
same area as tiger's, like those poor,
poor people in India. India is a really
scary place for tiger cat attacks.
Yeah.
Oh sure.
There was a documentary where they were
wearing these helmets and they had a
mask on the back of the helmet because
the Tigers don't like sneaking it.
They don't like confronting you.
They want to sneak out.
So if you're looking at them,
they'll leave you alone. No,
they figured out after a while that it
was masks, so they started jacking dudes,
even though they had masks on the back
of their helmet. Big Bite on the mouth,
but they have these, they're, they
have armored neck things to keep the,
cause the cat always goes to kill you.
The cat. You said something about like,
chimps would just eat you bears or just
eat you, but cats kill you. They kill you.
And then the EU,
because they have to kill every day.
A chimp can find some bananas and not
have to kill anything for a while.
So they have a different attitude.
That's the same as bears. Yeah.
That's why if you've ever seen
videos of bears eating other animals,
it's horrific because they're eating them
alive. They're just holding them down,
doing them just like they do a salmon.
Yeah. That's their style. Yeah.
Hold their head down and start chewing.
The only style of eating,
they don't ever kill you. That the
couple that got killed in the tent, uh,
new recorded.
They had the recorder on
and no one's ever heard it.
Just the one woman on that. Yeah.
It was the grizzly man. Right.
He got chewed up and it's all documented.
Well,
not only that would be like six minutes
long. I know. That's what I mean.
It was bad. So it took him six minutes
to find the find the right place too.
That's so scary.
But the guy,
the guy had a chance to get out of there
that I was out of his mind that I think
that was like a suicide by Grizzly bear.
It's one of,
it's one of my favorite documentaries. If
you haven't seen grizzly man folks, um,
it's unintentional comedy at its fine.
Its form. It is, it's amazing. It's like,
it is like a beautiful Coen brothers
movie documentary. Like if you,
you don't have to change a word of it.
And it would be hilarious if
it was over right. Artificial,
if you like made a mockumentary
and this was the mockumentary,
it would be brilliant. You'd have people
laughing in the theater, you know,
people who, well it's subtle
but it's great. And then
even a little over the top.
But he was trying to convince
people that he wasn't gay. Yeah.
I remember when he was walking with a
camera when the fucking dude is literally
walking with a camera going, well, if
I was gay it wouldn't be a problem.
Can't find a girl. If I was gay
it would be easy, but I'm not gay.
Like what are you doing? No, no
straight guy walks around with a camera.
I'm not gay. That's probably why he was
up there. He had an identity crisis. Yeah.
Poor guy figures out. That's a disturbing
thing man. When you see someone who's,
um, who's a burdened by
their actual who they are,
you know who they really are.
You know,
they don't want to accept the fact
that they're, well, they're the,
they've been born into this,
uh,
Mesmeric hypnotize society that,
that the,
they want to fit in, but they
don't. And the, and so the,
like a lot of Caesar's in the
past, you know, cruel bastards.
And most of them were gay,
really neuro and the voyage gay or were
they just like anything but just fuck
anything was there.
They were just savages.
Would they just nuts more toward the gay,
the little boy jury signed.
Can you kind of know? Well,
so I have always heard that when people
get molested by like a lot of molesters,
and when they catch them,
they find out that they also were molested
when they were young. A lot of them,
if you live in this savage Roman time
where everybody's just cutting people up
with swords, how people have morals, how
many people aren't fucking their kids,
you know? That's, that's why Christianity
was so important in back in the day,
you know, because it, it, it gave a whole,
a small amount of people a moral code.
Yeah.
They needed something to
anybody who think they were,
he would have probably taken way longer
without any sort of ideology for people.
Just agree to not shop each other up with
swords who probably take a long time.
Well, that was the whole thing. If you had
a knife, you had your sword, you used it,
and there was no, no way of butter.
If you weren't going to use it,
then you didn't hang out with
those people that used it.
It's like you're hanging
out at a bar, you know, the,
you know, the rowdies and they have
sores when they get drunk and no,
without sores. But you know what I mean?
Nowadays, if they had sores, it'd be,
it wouldn't be too many rounds.
Can you imagine how ridiculous that
would be if people were allowed to,
just so we're,
we're lucky people don't challenge that.
Just start walking around with swords
while they got guns in the south anyway.
Yeah. Oh, a lot of places, a lot of
places have concealed carry. Yeah.
And there's an argument for that,
really. Do you think so? You know,
the argument for it is that it's dirty
pee in the pool, guns already out there.
It's not like they're, they're, you
know, like, yeah, but they're like,
they're like magnets. So,
yes. In a way. Well, you know,
it's just like the martial arts, just
like martial arts. Same thing, man.
You know how to fight.
For some reason,
some guy in the crowd will find you and
challenge you because it's like light
understands leg. There's silly people
that have challenged like chocolate Dell.
I have this silly people that like,
people really don't realize how
ridiculous some people are out suicide by
suicide. They are just so stupid. I know.
It might actually think they have some
sort of a shot at beating his ass.
That's it sounds like you like,
there's no way everybody knows
that guy's a fucking, you know,
multiple time UFC champion, one of the
best knockout artists ever. Really.
You think guys picking on him get the fuck
out of? No, they really probably would.
There's gotta be someone that dumb. The
world is filled with morons. Oh yeah.
Well you know the, they're just
can't help themselves. They're,
they're like the wrong way or a tour it,
it's almost like a social Torat thing.
You know, where they can't
help themselves. They have
to say the worst thing,
the wrong thing and get whacked.
And a lot of that is like
what we were talking about.
Just they were abused when they were
raised. They were raised in correctly.
Someone didn't give him
the proper amount of love.
Something to does that phone's going on
in the background. You got good ears. Oh,
of course. I'm Deb. So are you going down?
Everything's going on
me. Yeah, man, you're,
you're suffering right now from
cancer, right? Is that what you got?
Prostate cancer. How, how
far is it slow moving in?
Apparently I've had it,
I guess there were about six years now.
I can tell you exactly when it,
when it happened,
I was in prison and uh,
all of a sudden my Boehner was in,
wasn't responding.
And uh, ever since then I said, oh,
there's something wrong and it or the
prostate gets big anyway on an old guys.
And mine was big. And then I went
in and had it checked about three,
four times and they couldn't find
anything. And that's like three,
four times a guys with fingers
up my ass, you know. So it was,
it wasn't that pleasurable. In
fact, one guy told me that joke,
he's getting an exam like that
and he told the doctor, he says,
well you stick your other finger up my
butt too, because I want a second opinion.
So I got,
I got to the point where I had
like for second opinions, you know,
and he said, Ma could be
either, I don't know. I don't
think spa. Yeah, you're okay.
And then my numbers,
my PSA or whatever it is,
some numbers that you get in. I just
had my blood checked today and I'll,
I'll know tomorrow if, if it's,
uh, you know, under control,
but apparently everybody has camp.
You're born with cancer cells.
Everybody has cancer cells. And,
uh, what happens when you get older?
The immune system, if it's, if it's, say,
taxed in any way, you know, we're
eating wrong during he wrong, uh,
it will get the cancer will,
uh,
increase in and eventually kill
you. But, but a, a cancer cell,
is it just like a Zombie cell? You
know, it doesn't know it's dead.
It's hap alive and,
and can only reproduce itself,
which is another Zombie.
And, and so what you do,
or in order for the good health, you
know, you, you eat things that, that, uh,
antioxidants kill cancer and
you stay away from stuff that,
that Pete's cancer because
they're like sugar for instance,
sugar will feed cancer. It
sugar is really the worst, uh,
substance on earth. But it's so
delicious. I know. Isn't it funny?
It's terrifying. It's Adam and even,
and she's cake is delicious. You know,
a nice piece of cheesecake. I have
sugar to make cheesecakes. Yeah.
You know everything.
Or You could get that a cheesecake factory
has said sugar free cheese cake yet
that might even be worse
though. Splenda, Splenda Bafour
him. Well, look at, look at,
uh, I've worked in a cookie factory for
a while and I couldn't eat the product.
Really. It was so chemical up,
there was so much crap in it.
So you saw what I put in and I saw what
went in and I physically could not eat a
cookie. He's there like Oreos
or something. Like, well,
they're Orioles are all
those marshmallow things.
And the only thing I could
eat was a marshmallow.
That was kind of organic and that was
that a marshmallows organic? Well, yeah.
I mean I done did it.
It didn't taste as bad as the big
chemical soup, like all the rest.
Well, you know, it was like
Lard. They put a big thing,
began a couple of gallons of lard
into the, into the big mixer,
like a cement mixer and then pounds
of icing sugar into the mixer.
And then you mix it all up and then you
pour it into a hopper and then it goes
over top of the cookies and it comes down.
And so that's how you make that,
that's how you make the center of the,
the icing small stuff is
kinda organic. Yeah. Yeah.
I know it's good for the skin. More
Marshawn was good for the skin can really,
yeah, the rub it on your skin. If
it's on the skin is asked like,
like a mask or something.
It was,
there's something Lanolin or something
in it that it's good for the skin.
That's interesting. I've never heard
that before. And everything else. Oh,
that sugar was horrible. So sugar is
just terrible for your body, period.
It gives you all the day,
all the problems. You know
what per weight, diabetes,
Chris Liebing lost a fight because his
body went into like a state of shock
because he ate a bunch of
sugar after the weigh ins,
before his fight with Brian Stann,
like he had really dieted,
he had really cut it down to the wire.
So he was just,
he just have something in his bus.
So you gotta think he's been eating
clean watches dive for a long time,
trying to get down to weight. He makes
weight and then eats a bunch of candy.
The word he was fucked man.
He couldn't fight. But later
that day I got sick. Yeah,
he's really dead. It was toxic, but
it's amazing. The poison your winter,
he didn't throw up. Did you feel, I'm
sure he did. I'm sure he did. He fought.
He just didn't fight like himself.
I mean he still fought well,
but he's just a tough dude.
But he definitely was compromised.
You could tell if you get sugar,
you know, naturally, you know,
fruit or something like that, that's
a lot better for you. You know,
bananas or something. There's
always something in there
with the sugar that, that,
that it's good for you. Well, that's
how you're supposed to get sugar, right?
That's when you pull it out and
then eat it by itself. It's like,
what are you doing there?
You're not supposed to get that much corn
syrup is in everything that's supposed
to be really bad for you. Right? Worst,
absolute worst. Isn't that crazy?
I go into whole foods now
shopping because I have,
I'm on a very special diet and I stand
in areas that I can't eat one thing in
that area, like all the
breads, I can't eat bread,
rice, all the starches. What
kind of a diet and you follow it?
It's very green, very
green. Kale and raw foods,
carrots and,
and it's actually quite delicious.
You make like a Kale shake. Oh
yeah. Oh yeah. I've been making a,
I got a Jew through natural juicery
warm driven juicer and it does it.
It's not a speed thing. And so what
it does, it squeezes the juice.
So everything and I juice everything.
Everything they say he should eat
the fiber too. I, um, the shakes,
the shakes are good for that.
Yeah, you can just cut them all up.
But somebody had a great idea, uh,
wanting to do this for our message board.
He said he didn't have enough
money for one of those uh,
blenders cause of Vitamix
blenders are expensive. He said,
but instead what he did is he juiced his
vegetables first and then took all the
pulp and then through all that in a
blender with the juice. So he like,
he made his own smoothie. I'm
like, that's pretty clever. Yeah.
So that way he's getting
all the plant fiber.
You're getting the fiber too because
sometimes like when you juice,
like after you go into that bucket where
all the fiber drops and you like pull
the stuff out, like shouldn't I
be eating this tour? You know?
I mean I guess you're getting up massively
concentrated form of nutrients if you
just juicing though. Yeah.
But the fiber gives you,
the fibers get too rigid
that no, he's toured. That's
what I'm talking about, dog.
We get older. You appreciate a solid shit
you can cook with that. You know that,
that bucket of stuff a lot of people
make like vegetables. Sure. Yeah.
You could definitely cook with it.
And my wife made carrot cake out of the
carrots. Oh yeah. That I couldn't eat it.
I don't mind.
I don't mind at all.
So do you feel better now that you've
all told me I'm the healthiest I've ever
been in my life. That's amazing. And I
got cancer. How long? That's incredible.
That's a great statement. How long has it
been that you've been on this diet? Uh,
two months. Two months. Wow. This, he
may. June. July. Yeah. It's three months.
Affects you a lot. Three
months. No, I'm not hungry at
all. One thing of, no, no, no.
I mean it affects you positively this,
oh, totally. Totally.
It just when you got cancer is
the nights are kind of long. Yeah.
Yesterday he started telling
scores and realizing,
oh know, Ooh. Yeah. I can see
the end of the game. You know,
it's a fourth quarter and
we may not go into overtime.
So. So you start to like
last night I had a bad day.
I've been doing most of my,
uh,
oil hemp oil or cannabis oil at night.
Now explain to people the
idea behind that because a,
I've seen that Rick
Simpson now stuff online.
Is he the guy who figured
out that a cannabis oil, one
of the doctors? No, doctor,
no, no, no. He's a funny,
the old farmer from Nova Scotia.
And how did he know?
Right wing farmer or rather than get old,
really old Canadian,
a right wing farmers. He
used to be right wing. Yeah.
Everybody in Canada, it was
right wing. You Kinda, you know,
guns and shit like that,
you know. And what he did,
he had melanoma real bad.
And so I dunno who turned him onto it,
but they said, hey, try something here.
Some Hash oil,
put some hash oil liner.
And he was doing to the doctor
who's in the documentary, uh,
for an operation to get most
of us jar cheek or something.
Well, no, near Rezai. It was near
reside, the skin around design.
It was going be taken out.
Oh. And so, uh, he, they put
the hemp oil on it, cured it.
Holy Shit. Sheared it cause your
Twitter spots on his body too.
And so he went in with a camera to the,
to the doctor and the darker
and then throw them out. Why?
Because they cured cancer.
That's a medical thing, you know,
why would the doctor throw him out?
Because if the word gets out
there charging, you know,
you know how much they charge.
I just paid Twitter need,
do think the doctor himself as a doctor
wouldn't want people to know about that.
If he came to the doctor and this doctor
wouldn't talk to him. The doctor really,
he'd went over the test with them and
said, you don't have cancer anymore,
you know, has gone
totally boom, boom, boom.
And so he tried to get the conversation
going and this is what cured me.
And the doctor would not hear it.
And the receptionist
literally called per security.
Where was this a part of the world? This
was in up in Canada. In Nova Scotia.
I could imagine that Nova Scotia. Well,
Vancouver is a very liberal, but uh,
there's a lot of parts of Canada there.
Certainly conservative or at least were.
That's amazing thing about these guys.
So what he did, he turned his friends on.
I had cancer because there's a whole
bunch of them up there. That lung cancer,
prostate cancer. How do you,
is it, it's applied topically.
If you have a cell,
if you've got skin,
you apply it topically and eat it as well.
You eat it for everything else,
like prostrate.
So for skin you don't eat it as well as
put it time engine. You could, you know,
I mean if you, it'd be like
these guys, where does it
doesn't make you high, right?
It's not who it does. Oh, it does hit his,
that's what I do it at night. CBDS.
What doesn't make you high, right?
Is that what it is? Is The cannabinoids,
the CBD that doesn't make you high.
It's a THC that get you some
dates. Anxiety, separate it.
The oral, I mean it's hash oil. Oh,
okay. So it's essentially just hash oil.
Hash oil. I call it hemp
oil. And everybody knows what
everybody's been saying. Oh,
that's good.
So it is the same thing.
So if you, if you take this as just like
eating a strong edible, Ooh, stronger,
strong. So you gotta be very
careful to be very careful.
I've had some of those liquid ones,
those little liquid come in like a,
like a little vial. The lose a day
of oil. The lose a day. A Cayenne,
I don't know who I'll lose a day.
Oh yeah.
Well this is what it's like.
I described it.
It's like standing in front of a cosmic
waterfall and you're just able to poke
your head through to the other side and
look at the back behind the waterfall
for little bit. And then there was another
waterfall bag. That's how high you get.
You get reality shot or
I could stay in bed. Hi.
So self examine story. It makes me wanna
apologize to everybody I've ever met.
Everybody I've ever met. I'm
so sorry. Whatever I've done.
I know I'm not a bad guy. I swear to
God I get out of bed. You know, I,
I didn't know how to take the medicine.
So the, on the video it showed him
take a little dollop on his fingertip.
So I did the same thing.
You know,
he sent me a whole kit of the oil
and I in these big plastic syringes,
you know, decorate cakes with, it's
super hard to make though. Right?
Apparently they make it next door at the
school. I, they just want an extractor.
No, it's, we want people to know where you
are. The feds, they're out their kid. No,
they're legally allowed to,
there's no such thing.
There's no such thing for real.
If someone in Washington DC is
listening to this and they decide,
let's go and fuck those guys up,
there's no law against that.
Do you know that that's the federal
law supersedes the state law as far as,
well, that's my whole, that's what
happened to him. That's my whole, uh,
uh, point of my life now
is to get this shit, uh,
legal so I can, so I don't have to
go around the corners, you know,
sneak around to get my cancer mitigation.
Yeah. Well when I was a kid.
Okay. And I listened to your, uh,
your albums and it was, they
were albums, vinyl, you know,
and who would have ever believed the
here would be still in 2012 and all the
children who listened to your shit have
now grown up and are still pass and
ridiculous laws and it's still illegal
and there's still rating pharmacies.
I think my, my, my job
on earth, it really was,
I was born around the same
time that they made it illegal.
1938 was when they made it illegal.
And I was,
that's when I came out
and I had been on the,
the pot I got turned on when I
was 18 by a Chinese jazz musician.
He gave me a Lenny Bruce
record and a joint holy shit.
And how he said enjoy.
And I was, I didn't know,
I was really scared of the joint
because I'd never had heard about it,
but it never smoked it.
So I smoked a tiny little bit,
put it up and laughed my ass off,
laughed until I was sick
until I was literally,
and then I had my friends come over and
we all listened about it never turned my
friends under the joint. No, I kept it
to myself. I didn't want to be the guy,
you know,
he didn't want to turn them all in.
Jj had known where I was going to
get another one. Uh, so that, that,
so it was that you,
it wasn't that you were worried you're
going to turn them into a junkie. No,
it was that, it was too good. It was
too good. I don't, I don't want to,
I didn't know where I was
going to get another one.
I had no dealer and never even thought
of it, you know? And so it lasted,
it was the best ever. It
was the best Thai. It was.
What was the,
what was the climate of light back then?
What year was 56 how
rampant was marijuana?
Nada. Nothing. No. He Canada, you
could sit in a concert and smoke it.
No one would know anything. Really.
They had asked you and you say, yeah,
it's Italian tobacco. And they go,
oh, this smells good. Yeah. Wow.
That's awesome.
Yeah. Yeah. You could walk
down the street. It's Morgan.
And then in the 60s,
uh,
I remember when I was in
Vancouver in the 60s. And uh,
the fort,
what singing producing four tops,
the four top, I think it was the four
tops, you know, the, uh, I'll be there.
They were playing at the cave,
a little club in the cave.
And of course there are the four
tops and black guys from Detroit.
So they smoked a bit joint before
the shoulder, put the ashtray,
but the g the roach and an
ashtray and went and did the show.
In the meantime, the meat
comes up, finds a joint phones,
a cops first, uh, first the front desk,
then the cops came and the
cops got the room next door.
And so when the fort tops
came back from their Gig,
they busted in the room and the arrested
before it tops and a Jewish comedian,
I forget his name,
and it took him down there and the tops
are telling his story after, you know,
it didn't last.
I mean,
Barry Gordy of Motown sent the
money or whatever it was in it.
It went away pretty quick, you know,
but you can get shit to go away.
Back then there was no TMZ or no,
yeah, no, you could. That disappeared.
But the funny thing was
they took him to jail.
They took the four tops to jail with
the comedian and the comedian that had
nothing to do with it.
He just,
he came up to the room for a drinkers
in the community. He was saying, Hey,
I'm not what these guys, come on, look at
me, look at me. Do I look like a four top,
I'm not the photography.
I'm sorry Joe [inaudible].
The Joe Pesci played that guy in a movie.
It was,
it was very fun. The climate back then
was much more innocent. It was innocent.
But then if where we live in at the time,
well,
I was in Calgary when I first got stone
Calgary first time and that's when I
quit school. I mean, I'm
going to in a couple of weeks.
Everything they said about Calgary.
Oh, I'll turn you on like Calgary.
I've been up there before. Did the Jack
Singer concert. I'm doing two shows there.
Oh,
we're awesome.
Right before the UFC at the
Jack Singer concert hall did
general, Yeah. Yeah. It's,
Oh, it's beautiful. Yeah.
Last time we did it and we
actually had people on the stage,
they fucked up at the ticket
somehow and put them on stage.
We put 50 people on stage with us. It was
crazy. It was great. There was so nice.
You didn't even feel weird about it.
It's singer. He's a rich guy. Yeah.
All those fun place. Belzberg. Yeah. I
grew up in Calgary. Oh. It was my shit.
That was my, she come to the UFC there
and a couple of weeks I could hook you up.
Yeah. I want to go. Do you want
to go? Wow. Let's see what I see,
how my cancer schedule illusion. Well,
if you feel well and you feel up to it,
let's not that,
not that at all.
It's just [inaudible] they got to
do to doctors and all that shit.
Now are you using chemotherapy
or no? No, no, no.
You just use my cancer.
My cancer is this very slow.
In fact, it's kind of weird what
they see to about my cancer.
They say usually we don't tell the guy,
you know? Yeah. Your religion. Yeah.
Usually we don't tell that guy
because by the time the cancer is bad,
you'll be done at some other causes. No
Shit. So that's, that's one of the things,
but I, you know, that's kind
of creepy that you're done
so well. They do that well.
How many times that we will die
before they get jaded? Yeah.
Well you don't have to
change your lifestyle. See,
I got a straight doctor
and I got a very hip, uh,
when a natural path and the
struggle to say gay dog,
the street, the street doctor, that's
why he wanted to test me eight times.
The straight darker. He kinda like,
Hey, whatever you want to do, go ahead,
don't worry about it. But
here's some pills. Take these
pills are very expensive,
but they'll keep your prostrate from
growing and it will keep the cancer cells
from growing in. So you'll be
okay for awhile. Side effects,
you might get Alzheimer's from it, but
that's down the line too, you know. So.
So my natural path, he
was the opposite. He said,
well yeah I take those pills but get
off them as soon as you can and uh,
and here's all this natural stuff
you take like green tea supplements,
not the green tea in a glass,
but condensed green tea is really good.
And there was all sorts of other stuff
because of the strong antioxidant,
what it is. Yeah, it's all in. Now if you
take the amount of oil, a lot of fish oil,
a lot of Krill oil and a lot of good
oil and that's because you keep your,
the Bones, everything else oiled and
the cancer cells can't stick to it.
And so the way that it works that
way, yeah, that's what sells.
We'll stick to things like are oiled up
wrestler. Yeah, like no internally. Oh,
you got to oil yourself internally.
And that's why water.
Why to be very careful with your water
intake because that's what happened to me.
I wasn't drinking enough water,
so dehydrated all the time.
And so I was a water deficient
and hydro would call deficient.
How would drink tea? I drink all this
other stuff, you know, sodas and stuff,
you know. But I really wonder if
you work out, you got to rehydrate.
It really wasn't water with water or
coconut juice is really good to coconut
water rather. That's a lot.
A lot of electrolytes in it.
But I went to a doctor recently and
I found out that it was three pounds
dehydrated because I, I've worked out
the night before and I'd, you know,
I had eaten, I thought I'd drank
enough, but he's like, you know,
you can look at it when they do like a
body mass index thing on you look at,
say like you're dehydrated. Yeah.
Yeah. And so, so for cancer,
cancer loves the hydro love. You fucked
up. Oh BC they like your weekend,
we'll figure it out that your,
your, your immune system,
your immune systems so busy
with everything else. And
I'll tell you another, uh,
I went to another healer and he gave me
a great tip I'll pass on to you and your
listeners is one way to cleanse
your liver and your kidneys,
which really just should be
cleansed as much as you can.
I heard it's a blowout weekend with
Jack Daniels. That's what I heard.
That's the best thing.
That's after I heard your liver
needs a workout every now and then.
You just got to put your liver through
the way you combine will you do it?
You get a bag of Celtic salt, sea
salt, sea salt, Celtic Sea salt,
rock salt. But it has all the
other minerals in it too. Huh?
And you get as much a gallon or so water.
Preferably not distilled, but you
know, whatever. Spring water spring.
What is he in a pure, pure
water. Pure water. You know,
you don't want to tap water.
Right? And, and what you do,
you put a pinch of sea water in a glass
and you drink it and you drink of salt,
pinch of sea salt in the glass,
drink it down and drink.
Try to drink as much as
you can with the sea salt.
And the thing is assault will make you
thirsty. So its impact. That's what,
that's why we love salt so much
because salt makes the thirsty,
the body needs water and the body will
do anything it can do to get water.
Once you put salt in it,
normally, normally your,
your body needs water and so it'll do
whatever in the salt makes you drink more.
And when you put salt in, in like the
Stillwater, the fresh spring water,
it cleanses your whole
body. You could have, um,
you know, it cleanses, like I say,
could act like an animal that sometimes
that it'll clean Jello but that you
should do that. Do that. At least
I'm doing it at least once a month,
once a month. And you, when you
define a pinch, what we say that is,
you think that's like a,
just a tiny speck.
You don't want to put too much it though,
right? You gotta be careful, right?
Too much. It just, it's too much. Well,
it isn't a dangerous at a certain point.
Well, how much, I know one of the wider,
the wider and the lobby softic salt.
It can see.
So it can't be a iodized,
right refined in any way.
It has to be sea salt.
Because of what you're doing.
You're putting minerals back into your
system and especially back into your
kidneys.
Just see that's where you're deficient
because none of the supermarket foods
give you minerals.
That's why we have a supplements.
You're talking about siblings.
We're just getting minerals.
That's all we're basically doing.
And Sea salt is the cheapest,
the easiest and nicest way
to get your minerals. Well,
another thing is a lot of
people don't realize that your,
your land that you grow things on,
he can't really keep growing things
on the same spot forever. No,
you deplete the minerals mineral soil.
And so then your vegetables become
mineral deficient and that's why you know,
you, the leafy vegetables
don't look as green and rich.
And if they don't look like green and
ranch, they're probably not as healthy.
And in the end, the non
organic fertilizer, you know,
that's so bad for the whole system.
What would it really creeps
me out as the soul. Um,
Monsanto thing or Monsanto is
creating these suicides, seeds that,
you know, they, they, they work
once and then they don't make,
they don't make seeds. Like,
you know, if you get it tomato,
you can't take it tomato cdot out and try
to plant that seed, that seed useless.
Killed them.
I love what they're doing because what
they're doing is they're identifying
themselves. Yeah. So we can
look at it. You go home.
Okay. Let me think. Give me the
organic. Yeah. Yeah. Uh, that's,
that's what they did with the coconut.
The Monsanto was the one that ran the
coconut. Uh, people had a business.
Did you know that? No, I have no
idea. Well, the coconut, coconut,
everybody use coconut oil. And it was
the healthiest oil on the planet. I mean,
to cook with the Ashworth
to, you know, grow your hair.
I remember when they said it was bad
for you. Remember that? Well that's,
that was one Santo real.
They were saying that the fat will give
you heart attacks and clogged up the
cholesterol bullshit. It's just the
opposite. Right. It's really good.
It's really good cooking oils. I one of
the healthiest things you can eat. Uh,
I got a great test now because I've got
a natural naturopathic doctor and he
says, what are you eating? And I, and I
name off certain things and you'll say,
don't eat that. Don't eat
that. I said, coconut,
eat as much as you want it.
The, especially the, um,
the coconuts from Thailand,
you know,
those are the ones that have the
most delicious milk with a white,
like a really stupid white silky.
Yeah. Yeah. The Thailand is good.
They're all good. It's all good.
They were Filipinos. I mean,
that's why the the
Polynesians, uh, you know,
their skin so beautiful and they got hair,
you know,
you don't such a healthy fruit to
eating the actual coconut itself.
So good for you.
And did you know here,
here's the fact about a coconut that I
didn't know about until my artist's son
in law told me. But the
coconut itself is, uh, is uh,
insecticide.
Really it admits things that kill insects,
Huh? The outside the
outside, the whole plan,
the whole plan can help the planet itself.
It's an insecticide.
It's an insecticide. And that's one of
the reasons that if you use coconut oil,
you know, keep the mosquitoes away.
No Shit. That stuff works. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. I've never heard of that
before. Work as good as off though.
[inaudible] off stinks, but that's
shit works. You know what I mean?
I don't want to get kind of bed
because I'm being crunching. No,
but the insects see the
coconut plant itself,
it took a few years to develop this,
but they needed a defense against
insects and birds and, and,
and imagine a coconut shell.
What a perfect home that would make
for how many birds? Everything. Yeah,
but you notice they're,
they're left alone.
They got this big leafy thing around
her that protects it too. But the,
but the plan itself is an insecticide.
It's pretty cool. It's amazing.
A coconut exists
at all.
I mean,
isn't it amazing that you get to chop
through all this bullshit to get to this
delicious center and look at it?
The water is and look at the soil.
It grows in sand, sand,
sand. So strange. Yeah.
A strange fucking alien plant.
That's so good for you. Yeah.
That's so good for you.
Good for you. You can use,
most of them are fortunate thing
about Americans is our diet.
So many people just are not eating the
proper amount of nutrients in vegetables.
Well, that explains for the psychotic
behavior of people a little bit.
Work is also to culprit. The people just
go crazy and I want to work anymore.
You know, it's fucking, we
don't, we don't work, man.
You and I haven't worked at a long time.
And when you work,
you know you're doing something you
don't like and you're doing it all day.
And that's,
most of us,
most of our country is filled with people
that are working well. The surviving,
you're, you're, you're surviving.
You know? That's why the, uh,
the immigration thing is such a thing,
you know,
because it's just people
migrating up where the food is at.
Work means food. Absolutely.
That's what it is. Sure.
And that's why these immigration
laws are kind of ridiculous because,
you know, it just puts people
in a position where they can
balancing mean to other people.
Well, it's a crazy situation anyway.
The only reason why it exists at all,
it's because we don't have jet
packs and portable helicopters.
You know what I mean? It's so easy to
fly around, so it's not, you know, if we,
if everyone had a fucking plane,
there would be no countries.
It would be ridiculous because you can
just go anywhere you want. You know,
they would, they would get over the fact
that I can't control people. You can,
you could,
you know,
they would have to control the airports
and then people would rebel, you know,
and take the reports back.
Everything in America is, is
all front. It's all upfront.
It's all a facade. There's nothing
real, you know, like when you,
when you get searched,
when nine 11 just happened,
I was in,
uh,
flying to somewhere Houston or are
applying to Argentina was somewhere,
but anyway, flew into Miami. Okay.
And you know, all those security,
they got the bags go into the machines
and your designs. Okay, well Miami,
uh, all these flights from
the rest of the world,
they just unload the baggage
beside the machines and people just come
in and pick up their baggage when they
go into the next,
next flight or in other words,
the third world country. And so
we're protected everywhere. La,
New York, or protect it, protect per
day. Then you go down to the butter.
That country, you know, Miami, you'd think
they would have some prediction there.
None. None. You could, you could walk. It
was a little barrier. You Walk Around, Oh,
there's my bag over there.
Or there's somebody back or let's
put this explosive over there.
No one would have,
are you given terrorists ideas?
I won't. You tell him him.
Where's a good spot to attack? I'll tell
you how to sneak in the country. Wow.
Puerto Rico. Puerto Rico.
Yeah. Yeah. How's that?
You can get a passport in
the Dominican Republic.
Then you can swim over to a or get dropped
off and swim to Puerto Rico and then
you dress up very whatever, you know,
and then you got your passport and your
green card and you get on a plane for
anywhere in America. Really? Is that easy?
That easy mastermind. You should
write books on how to break the law.
I know a lot of them, but I, no, I,
was there anything that you think
that there should be no borders?
Is that what you think?
You think that people should be
able to absolutely travel anyway.
They didn't want a part, you know,
people would seem to me, you know,
well if we legalize it and we
could tax, and I said, no, no. Why?
Why make work for yourself?
Just legalize it.
Just eliminate the DEA? No. What'd you do?
Did transfer everybody
from DEA to secret service.
They obviously need some,
some corrupt people in there and
your luminate the DEA so and so.
You make it Yay. And maybe, how
about using them for something good?
How about you use them for some sort of
an educational program or something like
that that they couldn't work?
He is, they're basically cops.
You'd have to give them another
cop shot. No, no, they're, they're,
they're criminals. They're,
they're beyond cops.
They're not just because you feel
like the DEA, their total criminals,
they're total criminals. And if
you're not, you're not in the DEA,
you have to transfer out because
you can't have one bad cop. And,
and now when you mean the really corrupt,
they're totally corrupt.
When we,
when we don't hear about the money that
remember all the money they used to find
the marijuana.
Yeah.
And now they're saying they're
selling more marijuana than ever.
We don't hear about the but
the money anymore, do we?
We don't hear about the millions of
dollars in drug money. That's just,
that gets confiscated. It gets confiscated
sitting in the court until the trial.
You don't hear about what
did they do with that money?
They split it amongst themselves
and they either they take the,
you notice it and also don't have
to account for it. Like when,
when for real, for real, they put it
in their pocket. They split it up 100%.
There's no doubt about it there. I can, I
can name, I'll name a, an instance. Okay.
I won't name the guy's name,
but he's a friend of mine from
Vancouver and he was done it here.
He's working for the hell's angels.
I can say that name because people know.
And his job was to deliver
the load of the BC bud,
which he drove down in a u haul
trailer right to a safe house.
And then he drives home and uh,
he just,
he got ratted out.
Someone ratted him out. You know, it
could have been one of the angels to,
you know,
you never know because they
control a lot of the borders up in
Canada. Anyway. Uh,
the DEA arrested him in front of the
Grumman's theater restaurant him.
Yeah.
Just him and handcuffed him.
And they had the big trailer of a weed.
What she showed me,
he showed me the weed and then he,
uh,
he gets taken to jail and he's in jail
and they won't let him use the phone or
anything. And all the, they interrogate
him, they say, where's the safe house?
So he gave up the safe house and
then about maybe a two hours later,
the jail who comes in and says, okay, you
can go kicked his ass out of the jail.
They just let them go and took the
money, let him go. He took the money,
took the weed they took to my the way
and let him go. And that's one guy.
That's one guy.
Is that what's going on now?
That's what these raids are all
about. Just the money, ground raids,
razor new for newspapers is
for the, for the, uh, you know,
the pressed and let them know
that so they can get their budget.
They get their billion dollar budget.
You know,
what's disturbing is that the
money that could be given to them,
rightfully through taxes, the money that
could be given to the state, you know, is,
is pretty substantial.
If, if they made it legal,
quite substantial going to really grow
it themselves. Some people are saying,
but you don't need to be able to,
you don't need to invent a new system.
We got a system in place is called
sales tax. If you open a store,
you pay taxes, that's all you do. If
you want to buy a bag of weed, you like,
you buy a bag of flour, it's the same
thing and you should be able to grow it.
Like he grew up fucking tomatoes
so you can grow your own tomatoes,
you should be able to grow your
own weed. You can, you can end.
The only trouble is,
is that, uh, because
of the greed involved,
that's why it's still illegal
because not only, not only that, the
people that the hemp, uh,
would replace, you know,
the forestry
well,
that's the most ridiculous things that
hemp isn't even psychoactive and it's
illegal. Yeah. Because of the paper
industry. And the pharmaceutical
mystery for the pain relief. There's
a show on TV yesterday about, uh,
the marijuana pain thing
and they can't come up.
The pharmaceuticals cannot
match a pot for what it does.
They cannot, and they've tried and
tried and tried. They cannot match it.
Well,
you gotta think that there's plants that
we have a symbiotic relationship with
and we know that there's a long,
long relationship that people
have to eating cannabis.
And we know that eating yet where
it doesn't even get you high,
when you just eat the plant doesn't get
you high. It's incredibly good for you.
That's by the way, the, the, the
juice people are juicing leaves. Yeah.
Yeah. And for cancer. And
that's what I'm going to,
when I find out and the leaves, you
don't smoke the leaves anyway. Right.
So when you, I used to use the smoke,
the leaves, but it's not as psychoactive.
Right. So that was powerful. There
was a, there's a thing about, uh,
sort of like a memory body memory.
So for smoking,
it's like you're smoking a bad joint or
we used to joke about it and say there's
weed was only good for selling to military
because then if they got caught,
they get tested there.
There's nothing in their blood.
They would be okay, but no weed.
I don't think it should be taxed
other than just just decriminalize it.
Leave us alone, you know, and then
the economy will, will, will blossom.
You'd be the guy to answer this.
When you hear people say, well,
the marijuana today,
it's not like the marijuana book.
Is that totally true or is it that what
I've read is that most of the marijuana
back in the day was not as
strong as it shit that's today,
but every now and then you'd get
some shit that blow your mind.
It's just as good as, I'll tell you
an analogy that kind of covers it.
It's like the 15 foot high diving
board. Okay. When you're a little kid,
they had those crazy long way down.
Then when you hit a young boy, ah,
this is nothing. I can go 30 feet.
Then as you get older and older and older,
that 15 feet plan the, you're not even,
you're not even walking
up the stairs anymore.
And it's the same as a pot part has not
changed. It's impossible to change it.
It's a strong, uh, back then
as it was, as it is here,
you can still get whack wheat today.
Sure. I imagine I've never had it,
but never had terrible weed.
He's had Labrador before.
I've had my share.
I haven't had bad weed.
I can't even do it. I think there's
a great difference between, um,
like really crap we'd, and
really how you sure. Sure.
How much of it back in the day,
like when you were doing
those Cheech and Chong movies,
how much of it was like high grade?
Was it hard to get high grade stuff?
Not really,
no.
The Vietnam War took care of all the
high grade we were getting is coming in
from this to ty. We'd like
a sativa. Sativa. Yeah.
That's the power for intellectual.
We'd put put you on your butt,
but you on your ass. But it makes
your brain makes of brainwork.
The Sativa. I mean all
that. It's very creative.
All the good weed.
That's one of the really unfortunate
things about the fact that it's illegal
that most people don't even
know what the difference is.
They don't even know that an indycar was
like much more of a sleepy sedatives,
sort of a feeling,
much more relaxing,
but in a sativa as a totally
different trip. It's,
it's almost like a totally different
drug. Yeah, it, and it looks the same.
It smells at seminar, but it's, it's a
completely figured out. Figured this out,
man. I mean, I've got cancer. You
can't get any worse than cancer.
Oh, that we does for you. It cures.
It kills cancer cells.
That's amazing.
It's just blows blows me away. It's
hard to wrap your head around it really.
I mean it's,
it's something that you can bring up
every day because it almost makes no sense
it that you get repetitive after a while
because it's so ridiculous that it's
illegal. When you stop and
look at it, it's like this
is, it's a magical plant. It,
you can eat it. It's really good for
you. You smoke it. It gets you high.
You can compare it well,
yeah, you can wear it.
Make a bass cloth ever live in underneath
it. You can make plywood out of it.
It's fucking waterproof.
It's crazy.
Probably the best Celio of plant
there is you make plastic out of it.
You can make plastic plants,
healthy plastic,
biodegradable plastic and plastic bags
that don't clog up the planet. Yeah.
People don't realize that plastic can be
made from plant matter can be made from
hemp.
One of the reasons why hamp was also
made illegal was that it was at the same
time we're dupont was coming up with a
chemical compound for nylon for now and
most ropes up to that date had
been made out of hemp. Hemp isn't,
it was Medable fiber. Hemp is the
best robe. Do, oh, by the way,
do you sell your ropes or the hemp?
I don't know what the fuck they are is.
You should check it out.
Should they shouldn't be hemp or
should be try to get them hemp
ropes from a ship yard. They have the,
you want to grip leather anyway, the,
the leathers at the end of them
so you can get it. I like that.
That you like raw fiber. Who wrote
field? It doesn't slip out of your head.
It's great workout if you'd done it. Oh,
I do it all the time. You do battle ropes.
Oh, that's awesome man. Look at
that. Yeah. So does my wave Shelby,
Tommy motherfucking Chong torn down
some battle ropes. Oh yeah. Dawn,
big body movements are so, so important
for health and for your, your,
your body's actual ability to work and
move. Well that was one of the reasons,
you know, back in the day when Arnold
Schwartzenegger lit up a joint,
you know, I said, this is
all the proof anybody needs.
Here's the guy that's really
the best built man in the world.
In the world.
Seven Times six have been times
that he's getting high and here,
here's a guy that he'd
spit out something if it,
if he thought it has sugar in it
or something, he would spit it out.
If you took a drinker
or a bite of something,
he's so careful about what he puts in
his body. No alcohol, forget all that.
But a joint passible review,
mine
gets high. He must've figured
that out when he was young.
I wonder when he figured that out. Well,
everybody figures out the same way.
Everybody asks me,
how did you get turned onto putt?
No.
What kind of drugs do you take?
And I say anything given
to me by a naked lady.
I smoked pot only a handful
of times in my life,
maybe half a dozen until I was 30.
And then when I was 30,
a friend of mine got me high and I
had a completely bad perception of the
effects of marijuana.
I thought it made you lazy.
I thought it was to
something that's sedated you.
I thought it's something
that made you and stupid.
And I wasn't interested in that.
And even though I had one experience
to the contrary when I was,
I was living with my friend Jimmy d
Teleo and he had a friend that was a big
pothead and we all decided to uh,
smoke some pot together.
I can never smoke pot needed the chimney.
So we got high and then I'm like,
Jesus Christ, man, I've got to drive
to a Gig. It was like two hours later,
it's still baked out of my fucking head.
And I had never gotten high before,
like maybe be,
he had to do maybe two or three other
times in my whole life before then. Right.
And only usually when I had
a couple of drinks in me,
so I have to drive and do this Gig
and I'm shitting my pants. I'm like,
I can't do my comedy. Hi. First of all,
the audience is gonna know him high.
I was only 21 or 22.
And um,
I had the best set I've ever had
up to that point. I was like,
this is crazy. Like I've never been so
smooth. I've never relax. Yeah. Relax.
Focus on what I'm actually solving
in the moment. Totally in the moment.
I was like, that's incredible. And I
was like, they can't be because of B,
because of the weed. I was so scared to
try it again. I never tried it again.
But I remember thinking that like, wow,
was it through? And I was like, Dude,
you just got lucky. Okay. You could have
been you it on stage in an hour earlier.
You would've fucking shit
all over yourself on there.
Cause I was shaky, you know,
back then I wasn't very good.
Yeah. So Tom, you're young. Yeah.
So I would bomb a lot.
She bomb like one of every five times.
It would not go well. So I was really
not, not looking forward to this,
not working out while it was high,
but it was the best bed ever had
up to that point. It was crazy.
Cheech and I,
when we first got together,
I had an acting group,
topless bar, the dancers,
dancers, you know, had them
acting and actors. Yeah.
Girls are the girls that would
go naked, you know. And, uh,
I'm thinking of doing one here,
but it's a lot of work. Um,
what's a lot of work dealing
with the topless girls used
to dealing with anybody.
But you do it a podcast
aren't you? I am, yeah.
I'm starting to in September. That's
awesome. Yeah, I'm going to, in fact,
you can catch me on at Tommy
Chong and Cheech and Chong logo.
Well,
let us know when that's taking place and
we'll tweet it and pump it up and get
everybody to listen then.
I think that's awesome.
Yeah. What was I saying? I forgot now
I forgot to, I forgot every guy we go.
Uh, we were talking about, uh,
bodybuilders get smoked marijuana. How?
It's obviously not that for you.
Uh,
basically the company's points
that we're supposed to be.
Did you have this doctor drew shit, man,
Don did you got caught? Uh, they, uh,
a pharmaceutical company had paid
him to encourage use of a certain
antidepressants as a, um, out
of a car. Yeah, he got caught.
They gave him 270 something
thousand dollars and he was correct.
He was supposed to, uh, talk about
the, the talking points of the positive
sexual side effects of
Welbutrin because like, uh,
like a girl would call up and say she
just got to changed her or her pills to
Welbutrin and now she's get having like
10 orgasms a day and doctor [inaudible]
like telly that could, that is one of the
possible symptoms. And like he's like,
they, he actually said that
talking, I did get busted.
I guess the company just lost a big
lawsuit. They just lost a, they,
they got, uh, a 3 billion something
dollar judgment against them.
So in, yeah, in the pro,
in the process of that they had to
release their paperwork and in releasing
their paperwork,
apparently Dr drew was a recipient of
more than a quarter million dollars from
them. It's scary, man. I liked,
I liked Dr. True, man. I,
that guy needs a joint. You know, you,
you get a little crazy, he's uptight.
He's a way uptight and got ticks. You know
what you're noticing. Do you know him?
Yeah. Yeah, I know him.
I like him. I like him.
A lot of done has a radio show a
couple of times. I like them a lot,
but he gets silly and he says to me,
he said to me,
he's having trouble with the next job
for, I said, what? What kind of trouble?
He said, well, if she's accusing me of
sexual harassment, I just get a lawyer.
Doctor drew.
So then I then teach it over on
the show and Dr Juice says to me,
hey, I took your advice, Tom.
I've got a lawyer, and Cheech
looked at me like, what?
What's going on here and fill me in. We
never did fill them in. That's funny.
I hate to hear that, man. It's a bummer.
That's the American way. Well, it's also,
guess what? Everybody needs
something to put them in check.
If you're not doing yoga and meditating
and taking some time to you so you can
get caught up in one way or the other,
the wrong fucking path that somehow or
another you're going to trip up. Well,
you got caps and clean out there wearing
a fucking tie every day and pretend
that you do no evil.
That shit. By the way,
is going to chew at the back
of your brain. You know,
you've committed yourself.
Does this crazy, unreal life where you
know you're not going to get fucked up.
You can't do shots with your friends. You
can't go to a strip, come, go, oh shit.
You can't do that. You're not. You're not
allowed to. You know, watch my reputation.
You're different. You're not an honest
human. You're a, you're a creation. Yeah,
and for me front and he
needs a little fucking,
everybody needs a little humbling,
like a natural humbling and it's
what marijuana does too. Well,
is that going to be a little natural
humble? Is that going to take them off?
He showed it. I don't know. I mean
hopefully he'll be acquitted. I like him.
I hope he didn't do it. I hope it's
not true. I hope if it is true,
it was charges. Yeah. I believe. I
believe they're investigating. I don't,
I don't know the full extent of it.
It's just been in the news lately.
But like I said, I liked
doctor Joe. He's not a bad guy.
It's just that these people,
they had this idea that they're
protecting people from something.
Here's the stance. It's not just, well,
why am I eating? I'm fine with that.
If you want to smoke pot, that's what
he always says. I'm fine with that.
If you want to get high, go get
high. This is what I'm saying.
I'm saying it can change
your fucking life and for the better.
It can make you a warmer,
more compassionate person.
It makes you closer to your
friends and your loved ones.
It makes you appreciate your dog more.
It makes food taste better.
It makes sex feel better.
Like this is ridiculous.
The idea that you would just poo poo it
and say, well, if you want to go get high,
it's not that man thing that can enhance
you. But you see what he's doing?
He's got one foot on the wall,
one foot on the shore,
and there's a liquor and he's trying to
be a celebrity. Yeah, there's a liquor,
there's a liquor. Uh, what do you call it?
Civilization. We're coming out of it.
We're coming out of the, the alcohol.
Civilizing. So you think so
we're coming out of it. Yeah.
You think it's ever possible to get out
of it? It's fun. People like to get drunk.
The only, they like to do
shots here. Anything else?
But you look at the movie Ted [inaudible]
and the biggest laugh and the biggest
thing was window little. A teddy
bear was doing a big bong hit. Yeah.
Well that, that is one thing
that is most certainly changing.
It's becoming more acceptable. Yeah. I
mean, when you were doing those albums,
like did you guys get hassled by cops?
Like did it become,
did it ever become a factor in your life?
Come when we got one Hassell,
we got arrested in Tampa,
Florida. That was where, um,
Jim Morrison got her breast,
it shown his wiener and well,
Janis Joplin, you got arrested.
There wasn't, she teaches
dad, uh, an a cop. Yeah.
Yeah. And so, uh, we were doing our
show and we just did a regular show,
but we didn't know there was
a $5,000 performance bond
posted and that the cops were
called in for any reason.
The promoter,
elusive $5,000 bond.
And so at the end of the show we're doing
a bit called the dogs where children
are running around our hands and knees
and Cheech walked over to a cop and he
picked up his hat.
The cop was facing out to the
audience in case the audience would,
would a riot or something, I don't
know. And that's all they do.
And, and the cups is there. That's it.
We're rusting Cheech and Chong and they
arrested us and took us to jail and give
us a mug shots. Good. Mugshots you
like him? Did you ask him for anything?
Like tee shirts? I think they're
on the tee shirts now. Yeah,
they're really good mojo shows.
Two guys. But Cheech was funny man.
Cause we're in the cell. First
of all, we're Cheech and Chong.
We just got up to stage 5,000 people, you
know, going crazy. Next thing you know,
we're being herded into a
holding cell and it was weird.
It's like we going to the green room only,
it's a holding cell and,
and there's all the drugs and everybody,
there was one old Chicano guy in there,
you know, and he asked
Cheech in Spanish, you,
what are you in here for it Cheech, he
didn't want to say you, we're lifting.
The cop sat with his teeth.
So he said, uh, drugs man,
Chicano Spanish. It goes, oh Tom,
I'm a black guy. Send it to you.
Just tell him a blank gang
here between I was his thing.
And so then the cop would
come by, you know, big, big,
like a storm trooper kind of cop would
walk by and he didn't give a shit who we
were.
And then there's an old picture
and then teaching area
we're talking about,
we're not sitting down because we think
we're going to get out of jail real
quick.
But then a lot of time went by and
pretty soon I'm not only sitting,
but I'm looking for a pillow because
I'm tired and there's just all these and
she's just still standing around.
And then the cop walks over and he says
to teach is you come with me and Gigi
Goes, Oh, my dad's a
cop. They're tired. Yeah.
My Dad's was the LAPD. Yeah,
I've been 30 years or 20 years.
It was funny.
I laughed.
They separated us and then in
a few hours later then we win.
That's what we look like.
Is that a trip?
Look folks who are
listening to us on Itunes,
we're looking at a video
of Cheech and Chong.
It looks like from the sixties rice, 1974
74 wow. It's all black and white. Yeah.
Wow. 74 they didn't
have color TV for, yeah.
You guys actually have
a really good website,
a Cheech and Chong fans.com which
just is updated all the time,
which I really like and they they,
they posted this recently on there and
there's a lot of different interviews and
videos on here there. Oh, Cheech
and Chong duck fans. Yeah.
That's very cool.
It's not cool.
There's not one of the coolest
things about the internet.
Is it fan created stuff that they make
for you? Does that still blow you away?
Taken over the world, man. We've
literally, you know, starting with Egypt,
Libya, you know the Internet
taking over the world.
The inner has a fascinating thing,
isn't it? Ah, yeah, look at this. Yeah.
Don't you love like the fan generated
stuff that they make for you?
Like like people that put up websites
like Cheech and Chong fans.com.
Isn't that amazing that you mentioned it.
Got a present here.
These are not a pipe's. Not
a pipes. Pipes. What did,
what does their necklace? They're not
a pipe. You don't pull the string.
Pull the string out.
I thought it was like a type of pipe pipe.
You don't pull the string. You put
the substance in this part here. Okay.
You don't do that and you don't lie.
Don't lie to me and you don't go and
smoke out of it. Spoke Gutter the same.
You don't do that because it's not a pipe.
It's not applied to the necklace.
That's awesome. And it's yours, Jill.
I'll bring you on that night man.
I didn't know what was
going to be an extra,
what animal had to give up his life
so I could have this not a pipe.
What is that? She's just a piece
of Antler driftwood. I follow.
It's Driftwood, uh, route actually
opt to beach. Oh really? Oh.
So I don't have to feel bad.
That wasn't like a little oh dear
that got shot in the head. Oh No.
Give me like a Ted Nugent pipe. It might
be a piece of wood from the tsunami.
I Dunno.
It might could be someone's house.
It might be shit pieces are probably
some kids toy floating around.
No, it's just a promise
center. Cut up a root.
Awesome man. Thank you very much
for that. Thank you very much man.
When is the Cheech and Chong movie
coming out? And I know you had to like,
there's an animated movie that it's done.
It's all finished.
It's in the can and no,
they're just figuring out a um,
release strategy. It's
an animated movie. Yeah,
they animate it a our old
bits. That's awesome. Wow.
It seems like such a good idea,
especially since that you do so much
work like on the Simpsons and things like
that. It's, it's a natural, I mean,
it's a natural way to go to you.
He'd imagined Cheech and Chong disc
doing voiceover work no more road.
You do you like doing the road every
now and then or is it just too much?
It's getting too much.
Is that what you've been doing lately?
Is just doing shows was
just once in a while.
There's to Shelby Shelby
now my wife and I go,
we went to Denver last
month or two months ago.
And before that, Cheech ne and Shelby,
when you guys got back together again,
that was a pretty big resurgence.
Ooh, big time. Two years. Two years.
Three years ago. Three years. It's
been going on for years and we,
we made a couple million, you
know, I remember when you, uh,
when you guys announced that
you were going to do that,
you guys had made up and you've finally
gotten back together. And I was like,
Holy Shit. We made up before,
before I went to jail, we had,
we were working on a movie.
Oh really? Oh that's cool.
And then I went to jail and in fact we
kept working on it with Larry Charles.
But it never a new line pulled out for
people that don't know your story of how
you got arrested in want of doing.
Tom is one of the most fucked up stories
that sort of in my eyes, a Pitta Mises.
The insanity of the Bush administration,
John Ashcroft Guy was insane.
And most people don't know this.
I mean if you, but if you look
online, John Ashcroft singing,
have you ever seen him sing?
He goes or she's never saw before,
is completely bat shit. The
titties. The summit. Yeah.
Cement titties.
He made them cover up statutes for the
first time in the history of that great
building.
And so you went and people wonder why,
why weren't you afraid of this guy?
Because he's a nutcase.
He was completely bonkers. It wasn't
my company. Somebody, my son being a,
an album, some dude from a, the
Internet. Whoever you are. Dude,
I just want to thank you.
Thank you so much.
I totally don't even remember who the
guy was, but he sent me a fucking album.
It was an album of John Ashcroft and
another guy singing gospel songs and they
were just one more horrific,
horrifying in the next you just,
the more you listen to them,
the more you thought of him. Sweaty
and black socks. Fucking little boys,
you know something going on.
There's a darkness and the
other side of this fucking coin,
like this is not coming
from a healthy person.
This is a crazy form of art
you're trying to sell me on. When
they went to his hospital bed,
when he was sick or something and
trying to get him to sign, what was it?
What were they trying to get them to
sign? A confession or something? No,
I think it was okay. Torture
or something. Ashcroft.
Ashcroft was the attorney general.
He wouldn't do it. He wouldn't do it.
I'm no sorry. I knew that he
was a crazy man. Oh, he does,
lady that put me away. Mary Beth's
Buchanan. What about, what was her deal?
She was a cheerleader.
A little town in Pennsylvania where
the nine 11 plane went down. Yes.
And because she was a prosecutor there
that give her prominence and they made
her, made her the chief of
the prosecution. Oh my God.
Yeah. She was like the chief prosecutor.
Oh. And the first thing she did was when,
after the bomb companies and
Tommy Chong and it, by the way,
you weren't even telling the bonds, your
some son, he was making them his own.
Yeah. And you didn't even have
anything to do with it. Well,
I'd sign them east side. I'd sign. That
was your job and they went after you.
They went after him. Well, what they did,
they went after the company
and which was very, very funny.
We got the documentary called Aka Tommy
Chong. I know about it. But uh, yeah,
they tried to try to,
Dan trapped us,
they tried to get us to send the stuff
to their place and we wouldn't do it.
Finally sent an undercover
guy into our company. And
next thing you know,
I'm a before for bones while,
but I'd Milt Milt is shit out of it.
It's true.
Right.
That really gave you a nice boost once
you got out of the pokey have gave me
while I was still doing material.
Yeah. Still doing well when I was,
and I bring it up in conversations
to, you know, when I was in jail,
I know sometimes one time
I was with two judges,
two judges at a dinner party and,
and I that we got the dark and
then the next thing you know,
I'm telling him about jail and they're
kind of giving me the, Oh shit,
look like they shouldn't be talking to
mission and be listening to this now.
And then I'll talk to a square
dude about getting high, you know,
and you see a look in their face but
are looking for the exit. Okay. If
that's what you're into. Oh,
I liked, I'm straight edge.
I like my scotch or water.
I don't mind a little booze in,
but I don't smoke dope. And these judges
are cool. We're friends with them. Um,
uh, one's, uh, it's very good
to have a judge for a friend.
You know, I had given you help me. I
got all kinds of friends, you know,
you must put it pretty funny. Yeah,
there's a whole set of different,
different people that you're
known being an outlaw,
but it's the silliest law of all time.
I'm kind of like a stoner, Paris Hilton,
where they looked at me at a party.
Everybody,
we have Tommy Chong here,
we can all get high. No,
and he's not wearing underwear.
Is it annoying how many people
want to get high with you?
Well, it keeps me from going into places,
you know, like I'd like to do, you know,
the playboy mansion pod thing every
year, but I can't do it, man. You know,
he had too many fans. You know, too many
people want to get high with you all.
They wanted to take pictures,
right.
And telling stories just swarm on you
and be on their podcast. You know,
like that's how you're here,
man.
This phone be in Tommy. John, do you,
do you smoke pot with strangers? No. No.
Me Neither. No, I don't. If, I don't
know it's, it's too much risk. Sorry.
I tell people I don't,
I quit smoking and I usually don't.
I have to really know where the source of
the weeders from before I'll accept it.
Then we'll give it friends of mine,
you know,
tell him this is where I got this shit.
That's exactly what I do. I'm like,
it's just certain people that
I get I with that I know.
But I mean it's unfortunate but I've had,
I know one guy that definitely came
up to me that was a cop in uh, in,
in Cleveland. I'm positive this knew
something was going on. You know,
he's asking me where I could get
DMT. Oh. And the way he was asked,
he said we had a crew cut.
I looked like a trend.
He did MMA and I'm looking at this
dude and I'm like, cause you want what?
Strange guy that looks like a cop
asked me where to get illegal drugs.
I wouldn't want to talking about,
I once had two cops worked their
ass off for me. It was funny.
I had a nightclub in Canada
and then I had to nightclubs in one cut,
closed down and saw it and they
sold the building. So then I moved,
I had a back room, you know,
so I was fixing up a back room,
did take over the other club.
And uh,
next thing I know I got to a
man and a girl with headbands,
they come up stairs and they're like,
they're not hippies by no means.
The headbands looked like a costume look
like they're going trick or treating
a, this is how they dress swimming. So
he said, so, so what's going on up here?
And I said, well, I'm just putting the
club together. He says, I need some help.
I said, yeah, actually I do. So,
okay, so they're in there helping,
you know,
what were you thinking at this time?
I'm looking at them because they thinking,
wow, I could use a help, but who knows,
I'm not going to pay him
anything. You know, maybe let
them in the club later, pre,
you know,
so they're moving tables and washing
floors and so weird they show up and start
working. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And they were
working and good workers too, you know,
the more I look at him and I said,
these are hippies.
Hippies will hide behind a wall to
see you or they're working. Okay,
I'm going to here. So, so they worked
and then we had a little break, you know,
when we're sitting around talking.
So I said then there's brief from
odor from Saskatchewan. Yeah.
I've been here, out here.
Oh, a couple of days.
So, um, so, um, have you ever got high?
Oh yeah. Get high on the fact
as well. Ever done acid said.
Yeah. Oh yeah. I love acid. Yeah. I just,
well tell me about your first acid trip.
The guy goes,
I don't remember.
He said, I said, just a minute.
I got to go to the bathroom.
And I went to the bathroom. I
did a little dance there. Carbs,
carbs through fucking cops. That's
the Lens. I went back. I said, well,
let's get to work. We got a lot of work
to do here. So you just put them to work.
So he scrubbed the
floor, man, I had a man,
there's Headbanger's
soaking wet with sweat man,
their work their ass off.
And then I got on the phone,
I phoned everybody I knew.
You know,
cause we just say the door lady used
to sell weed right at the door kind of
club. It was so, so then the club filled
up and they stayed the whole time.
They didn't go home
and change or anything.
He got their little headbands or did
they change? No, I think they did change.
They went home is okay, we'll see
you back later. And then he came,
sat together and they look like recruits.
They looked like recruits.
I mean they were so, so, so out of place.
And I told everybody and so everybody
would walk by and like they were on
display.
They just walk by and look at the
clubs you're looking at it and walk by.
It was so everybody kept an eye on them.
And if you want to smoke weed,
just made sure you knew where the cops
were. Yeah, yeah. Well first of all,
you don't do anything, you know
they're cops. So no one does anything.
So no one did anything.
Hey Claire
and the lady, you know, all of a sudden
it was the cleanest club in, in town.
So now at the end,
did you ever let them know that you knew
they were coming to us? Oh No, no, no, no,
no, no. Don't give that. How'd you
end the night? Well, they just left.
They just left. They couldn't make a
connection and they knew they got spotted,
you know, you know I'm cool. Cool.
But there's a lot of people
that he never fucking cops, man.
Imagine how paranoid they would
have been if you got them high. All.
Oh my goodness. I had never thought
of that. I kind of glad though,
because I didn't want to get arrested.
You know for, yeah, but what if,
what if you made them smoke weed at first?
What if you said something like,
listen man, I don't know
you. So if I don't know you,
you got to smoke the weed first
and then the guy smoked weed,
like I'll smoke to eat later,
but you got to smoke to eat first.
You imagine what that would be
like? Get, I'm high as fuck.
And especially if they don't get high,
but they didn't test guys blood
and shit back then. Midday. No,
they didn't know how to,
now they test people work at ups
and then you get a p and a cousin.
I was in jail with a bunch of ups guys.
They got caught.
They were the Jimmy can connection.
Oh they bringing it over
from black guns,
all black and then all the ups.
Fedex a man. Why has it, why else
would you want to work so hard for gps?
A whole connection. That's what I'm
saying. You know, that's why, you know,
just legalize this shit. We can
figure out how to grow it and pack it,
move it. Well, it's,
we were suppressed and we're
just accepting the fact
that were suppressed. It's,
it's people they don't realize,
hey, how much of a suppression,
welcome to the slave.
Yeah,
we're world. The world of
world of color. Yeah, that's,
that's exactly what pot
really turned everybody into.
We got turned into people of color,
you know, like Mexicans and blacks,
you know. That's why they called it
marijuana. You know, they never it, oh,
they're smuggling hemp across the border.
Right.
They named it is a wild Mexican tobacco.
Right? It hasn't, it no mirror marijuana.
Just slang for a pot.
That's all.
I thought it was originally slang for a
wild Mexican tobacco. Couldn't be. Yeah,
that's what I thought it was. But that
could be harsh. It to be. But then that,
that was one the ways William Randolph
Hearst had actually made it illegal.
It's telling people that
Mexicans and blacks were taking,
you're not making this up,
but they were actually stories in the
newspaper and the Hearst publications that
said there's a new drug,
it's called marijuana,
and these Mexicans and blacks are
taking it and they're fucking,
all the white women horny for weapon.
They use shit.
They use the same argument
with heroin and cocaine,
except, uh, the, well, the cocaine and
heroin was also check the Chinese opium.
So they've just,
they've just made a faulty connection.
But their logic is sound at the bottom
end of it is everybody wants to fuck
white women.
So they just distributed,
everybody wanted to fuck white
women to all sorts of shit.
Well the vitamin C makes you want to fuck
white women look or eating oranges and
fucking these girls.
My line for years, you know, because
when I was a musician, you know,
I ended up in a black band, right.
And I played from town road,
Salisbury.
And I tell people on stage,
I got so black guy ended
up marrying a white woman.
Was that where marijuana was
most prominent in the early days?
Was it in the jazz culture as reaper?
No habit stick a tee.
How would they get sick and ti,
how were they getting it?
Oh, Puerto Ricans probably.
I don't know who. Kim Mexico.
I mean if you're in La, you know, any,
any Chicano on the street corner, right.
Would sell you anything.
You could get a pound for $10 one or $2,
you know? Really? Yeah, you could
do it. A lot of it would be Kurt,
you know, but oh yeah, put
some rocks in there. No,
they do everything back in the
day and then, and then the, the,
the dealers are the guides who would
break it down and we'll a little pinners
little tiny joints and sell
them for a buck a piece. Wow.
And they barely got you high.
Right. Just Nice. Just Nice.
Especially if you're a musician, you
know, you don't want to, you know,
you don't want to be in
coherent, you know? Yeah. Take a
couple of hits. Oh, just get
that edge knowing him. Boom.
That's exactly what it is. You can
definitely go too deep though. Yeah.
And isn't it funny,
I've never heard heroin addicts say that.
I've never heard cocaine.
As you say that heroin addicts,
you ever talked to someone who's in the
middle of heroin? They just love it. Oh,
you just love it.
It's a weird feeling to think that there's
something that can make you feel so
good, but it's so bad for you. Well,
what it is, this is my, this is my
definition of a heroin high.
It's really, you've died.
That's a feeling of death. You've had
it. No, no, but that's my, this is my,
is what you think of this. This is why
they go back to it all the time, you know,
because for that few seconds,
because it basically it is,
if you'd say it gets less than that,
as you get older, you know, as you get,
your body becomes immune to it, then
it becomes a, what do they call it?
Chasing the dragon. Oh yeah, yeah. Well,
you never get it. You never get enough.
You never get into it that first time.
But the first time that, that Ma warmness,
it comes over you. It
said, it's such a feeling,
to me it's the feeling of what
Michael Jackson was looking for.
He was looking for that feeling, you
know? And that's what heroin addicts want.
They want that peaceful,
calm, gentle, sweet.
Everything makes sense. You
know, the notes are so big,
you can just touch him and you know, and
that's what, and when you're making love,
oh, I mean, there's, there's,
um, would he call it ecstasy?
After ecstasy?
It just goes on and on and on.
But the second or third time
your body starts, you know,
create, you need more and
more and more. In other words,
your body shuts down because it is
a poison. It, it really is a poison.
And what a weird point. And once you
get into your system and then return,
it gives you unbelievable feelings of
love as it breaks your body down. Yeah.
Is it that or is it just
that it stimulates these
unbelievable feelings of love
and they force your body to do things
that are totally unnatural because of
these chemicals in the system.
And then the downside is you crash hard
afterwards. What's the downside again,
to balance out downside? You get sick.
Yeah. He literally, you get sticky cramps,
you, it's rolled up you,
you get nauseous. You're,
your body's going through
all kinds of changes.
I had a friend that came to visit me
in La and I didn't know it at the time,
but when he came here he was trying
to kick it. So as it got to my house,
he was sick for like a whole week
to do it. Never got out of bed,
just laid around all day.
He had the flu. Yeah.
Wouldn't tell me what was wrong with them,
but I mean that's what he did.
That's how he kicked it. Yeah. As soon
as this terrible thing to watch in jail.
More people oxycontin. Yeah.
Oh, are they filled out?
The whole jail was built Google.
Yeah. I got goat when I was in jail.
And so they give you the pure no,
it was some kind of shit
for it and in my mind, God,
gold got cured real fast. I
had a whole shitload of really,
and the guy, the guy, the pill
freak across the way. Eagles
want to sell that. You want to
sell that? You can have a minute.
Oh Hey. Thank you man. Thank you.
How hard is it to get drugs in jail?
Well, the trouble with drugs, you
can get anything in jail, but you,
you get tested if you're a target,
you know, move with me. Right.
I got offered to join every day.
Really tested almost everyday.
He thinks that people were trying to
set you up totally. Totally there.
Then that was her job. Right.
And they got to know what to do.
Let's fuck with Tommy Chong.
Let's get a headline or do here.
How bad was was chair? What was
the experience like? It was good.
Like going to camp was a camp
like boy scouts or army cadets. I was an
army cadet, so it was like going to army.
Cadet camp was old people, you know,
they had me in an old dormitory,
but it was um,
what do you call it?
Chalk Line around the perimeter and you
couldn't step over that chalk line or
you get tased,
you get yelled at,
get your ass over there. What
are you doing over there? And um,
but actually it was, it was like
a spiritual, it turned for me.
It turned into a spiritual retreat
because I took some books in there,
including the Bible.
And I really,
really started a search for, for,
yeah, I'm here. Might as well,
it's a monastery, might as well use it.
And so I did. So I did, I read a lot.
How many, how long were you in jail for?
Nine months. Nine months. Nine months.
I'll tell you how long,
nine months is those tubes of toothpaste?
The big ones? Three. Three, yeah. Wow.
That's a long time.
I'll fucking time it doesn't,
it seems like when it lasts
forever it doesn't. Yeah.
And what's her three of them?
That's a long fucking time. Yeah.
It's almost a year of life.
Brushing my teeth every day.
It wasn't a brush your teeth to get
something bad out of your mouth.
[inaudible]
toothpaste.
It's funny, I got hit on one
time. One time. One time.
Actually I never got,
not in jail,
but I never got hit on was in
jail. No too. Did you see any rape?
I saw the Barbara was gay. The
Barber, the barber guy. Cut Hair.
How much did it cost to watch?
Everybody's in, mate. There's no,
no work that the employees are,
the guards would have to wear their
uniform in the scorching hot sun and like
the river choir, you
know, one of those things.
And we're laying out there getting
Suntan and the guards are walking around
every once in a while. Could you
bring me some Suntan lotion please?
And the guard said, what?
Oh, nevermind. Nevermind. I
thought you were someone else.
Will they nice to you ever?
No, they're real nice.
They had a law that they had a rule,
a Tommy Chong. No, with Tommy Chong
rule.
And one first day I was there again,
gardening Gonzales. Next thing you know,
he's in my, in my cubicle. Hey John,
I'm a big fan. I love you guys.
Ah, I'd go back, blah blah blah.
And so then I was on the
phone the first time I got,
I wasn't allowed on the phone
for two weeks. And then I
finally got on the phone.
I get for my wife, you know, and we're
talking, she's how is it? And I said, oh,
not bad guard came by my cubicle
and it was real nice, you know,
big fan.
And so then I hung up the phone and five
minutes later they were listening on
the phone, just report to
Central Command and control John.
So I go down to the command
control. I said, all right,
who was the guard that came,
said Hallelujah.
I says, I don't know.
They all look alike to me.
Was He, was he Mexican? Was never,
it never really saw his
face or then they do,
they gave up on me or an hour. Wow.
But yeah, they're looking for snitches.
Jails are run entirely by snitches.
They have a snitch culture
really. And what it is. Yeah.
That's why a lot of guys get a lot
of time, you know, and what they do,
the gels out Kimbark
bargain was the once was.
A lot of times we'll knock
out the time if you really,
if you give up people, that's ridiculous.
That seems like that should not be fair.
That's cheating the whole genesis
going of course people in to do things.
The whole jail systems cheating. Well,
the whole fact that it's private test,
that's terrifying isn't it? Hid. It is.
And in the jails are really
run by inmates, you know?
I mean the guards have some control, but
there, especially at the camps and camps,
I mean there,
if there's a hint of violence,
you're out of there and in a vive and look
like you want to be violent, you know,
they'll, they'll get you out of there
because he had old women guards. You know,
people that you know weren't
going to hurt anybody.
They were the year guards walk around
with her uniforms and stuff on.
But I,
I got into the Indian sweat lodge
society and that took up a weekend,
you know,
it starts Saturday and then sweat Saturday
and then have to clean up the place
Sunday. And you do this while in
jail? Yeah, there was an Indian,
we had an Indian garb grounds and,
and it faced away jail at the jail.
And the camp is still do,
it's mandated that the native American
Indians have their form of worship and
their form of worship is a sweat lodge.
So every jail is what?
Every federal prison in American.
Wow. They had to go to fascinate.
You had to go to court to do it.
And some are better than others
and some are very bare bones.
But we had a phenomenal place. We
had a, the guy had been in there for,
I don't know how many years
they took care of the grounds,
maybe 15 years, something
like, but he, he,
he gathered rocks. There's a
desert, it's a desert. So he got,
he got rocks and he had
little fences made the,
and then he had a area, therefore
the sweat lodge itself, you know,
it was all packed earth and
then it was like a tp, you know,
it's a or a Hogan and then they covered,
ours was covered with
plastic and rain stop,
you know, and then, uh, the sooner
then the big bonfire next to it.
That's what really attracted
me was a bonfire. We had
fire in prison. Right, right. You know,
it's on her crazy all weekend
and what they would do,
they leave you every weekend.
I'll be an Indian like that in a minute.
First of all, it's not an
Indian. How stupid is that?
We still use the term God damn.
It's the lost whatever.
They lost Chinese.
One huge mistake from 1492.
And we're still calling them. And the guy
that did it with such a piece, a shit.
We celebrate the day. Columbus Day. He's
a God damn serial killer. Yeah. Yeah.
They did horrific things here about what
his soldiers did to the children of the
native Americans. Sure. Dash
and babies' heads on rocks.
Stories this bloodbath. Yeah.
So, so the native Americans and,
and there was maybe a house,
I have a one
in, in our camp, back to
his name. I forgot his name,
it'll come to me. Anyway. He, uh, he was
head of the thing. He was an old biker.
X biker had been incarcerated
most of his life.
And David, I yellow, David Ilm, just,
he wore a headband and when you
joined the sweat, sweat lodge society,
you're allowed to wear headbands.
And so, so like a gang, you know,
the headband came really low
round his eyes and he had,
he wouldn't talk to anybody and he
worked at, in his Indian grounds period.
They a lot of that.
So all he had to do
that's bad ass. So he wasn't
even really doing time. No.
Don't know what kind of time
once you get that, because the Indian
grounds faced away from the prison.
So it was like you're on the grounds
and you're looking right out into the
desert and the desert,
who's magical place?
The desert had packs of wild dogs.
We were close to Bakersfield.
And feel Marlin, you know,
maybe 1520 miles from Bakersfield and
people would drop up puppies and on one at
dogs or you know,
just strays and just kick him out into
the desert and the dog's packed up.
And the leader, the of this one pack
was a big rottweiler. Holy Shit. And,
and, and they had everything from
little poodles, two big ass rottweilers,
German shepherds,
all kinds.
It the one dog that vicious looking one.
Anyway,
Hair Doberman. Yeah,
there's a doberman. And,
and what they would do a shitload on
wild rabbits in Taft and at night they
would come on the lines like hundreds,
probably thousands of rabbits
would commode on in feed
and piss around dogs with
Jack Them. It was the dogs. They
never come and do the camp at all.
They would never even come close.
But what they would do,
and we've watched it from the
Indian grounds, they would,
there's bramble bushes,
you know,
clumps of thorny bushes.
And the dogs would chase the
rabbit into the, into the bush.
And then the little poodle would,
would go in and Buddha mode really.
And the big ones would be waiting
at the end. He had a horse track,
they had a strategy man,
they were so brilliant and,
and we tried and we also had a wild
ground squirrels and you'd feed them by
hand.
And the groundskeeper was a whole,
almost as many ground
scores as a were prisoners.
And we'd walk around this track and take
the food that they tried to feed us and
Peter to the ground squirrels and the
ground squirrels got fat when one got so
fat,
couldn't get back down in this hole.
And to keep the ground
squirrel population down hawks,
they had these beautiful hawks way up
in the light tower and they would sit
there and watch the ground
squirrels and everyone said wow.
The ground squirrels would be looking
up and they always had to look out and
they'd do some kind of
whistle or something.
If the hawks were coming down then
they'd go into their holes. Wow.
We fed them until they got
so fat one got so bad. And,
and the, the, the, I hung up
with all the bikers, you know,
the old hell's angel types and no bikers.
That's,
that was my set. Uh, and uh,
we're sitting around and
they would play cards and,
and smoke cigarettes outside,
outside the dorm.
And one of the bikers was a electrician
and part of his job was keeping all the
lights working and the lights where
they had the nest was flickering off,
I guess an ascot tie tied
up with some of the wires.
And so he had to crawl away up, I know,
40, 50 feet up to the light tower.
And he got up there and he
says, he found, he found, uh,
what we call it. I forget the ground,
the fact ground squirrel patty,
they found him dead up there.
He couldn't get an Sol soul.
And when I got Americanized, yeah, one
of the bikers, what are the bikers,
you heard the story and he
looked at the tower and he goes,
ain't no way in hell that ground
squirrel crawled all the way up there.
Oh,
he was serious. Oh my God. Oh Man.
Put on this earth to dig holes.
There were some comedy and in prison,
I mean that was just one of them. Are
you friends? Anybody from jail? Alright,
everybody. Yeah. Everybody you just
want to touch. One guy is, um, he's uh,
uh, caddy for, um, uh,
Jeff Overton is a professional golfer.
He's watched TV and watch everyone
saw you see Jeff Overton and, uh,
Eric Larson was my,
he was the guy,
one of the first guys I met
when I went there. He was,
he was doing time for cocaine.
And what happened?
He was just a caddy and he was just
buying, but the dealer got busted.
And so the dealer, the cops
told the dealer, give us a
name and we'll let you go.
And so she,
the only name she knew it was Eric Larson
because he was mark Calca Becky's a
caddy at the time.
And he was the only famous one.
And so Eric fought it, you know, because
he was just a buyer. He wasn't a dealer,
wasn't right distributing and
nothing. Right. And so they told him,
if you fight it, you go
with 14 years. And he,
he won the first case.
Oh my God.
They refiled the charges slides the next
day they refiled to charge them with
something else because the feds
are their creative muscles there.
They want to get it. Dave wanted to
get it done, they want to get you,
they get you. And that's the
way the whole drug culture is.
That's jail is falling Pharma.
And so he ended up doing fortunate 14
years and his only crime was buying a
couple of bags of coke for, for
other golfers. So sad. But anyway,
I met him and he was at the
time he was brilliant guy.
He's got two college degrees when using
in prison. He was in there for 12 years.
It's so fucking sad.
He went to school and any,
and he took advantage of it and learn
how to grow grass and he had a garden.
He grew his own garden
and then he ended up,
he tried to get me to work out there
with him, but my time was too short. And,
but I ended up going out to
the garden all the time anyway.
And he would cook for us
at night in a microwave.
And I had the best meals,
I swear to God. Yeah.
All fresh garden growing
vegetables. No Shit. It was great.
It was great. And every once in a
while we'd take her fucking years, man,
whoever did that as evil,
that they belong in jail,
that was a part of that. They belong,
they belong. I held it should be removed.
I helped dairy goat because when I met
him, he was a very bitter, yeah, you can,
as you can imagine,
because he not only went to jail,
but he went to the toughest
prisons out there and he did his,
he did rough time for about five
years, the roughest time ever. And uh,
and when I met him, you know, he was
very bitter. And so I started constantly,
I'm a little bit, you know, tell
him, you know, hey, you know,
you can't let prison each whip.
Like it's just amazing that someone
could do something like that to him for
nothing. For a personal
choice issue. The dealer,
the dealer could have saved his and said,
you
know, why did she turn him in? Just a
piece of shit. Yeah, exactly. She just,
she see I, you know, bite the
bullet and take your time.
She should run away. But I,
I potentially got Eric and then I
made friends with the drug counselor.
Oh really? And so yeah, big friends.
I remember when you got out man,
I was listening to this interview and
it made me sad because they were testing
you and you couldn't get
high so you would like, uh,
he put yourself in the state of mind
and you can actually even like give
yourself the munchies you were saying,
Oh yeah, yeah. It's all mental. You can,
you can re reenact that feeling anytime.
That's why Cheech and Chong
are so important to a lot
of our people that because
you just mentioned her name and all of
a sudden everybody flashes back to, hi.
Hi Lou Rosa.
You got a whole audience.
There wasn't that many people from that
era that were defined by marijuana like
you guys were. I mean you
guys are the deaf, definitive,
like I know people that would say
let's go Cheech and Chong it. Yeah,
that's what they say. Yeah. Like you
know when they want to go get high,
they'd say let's go Cheech and Chong and
everybody knew exactly what they were
talking.
So
yeah, there was no compromise. We
weren't guys, Hey, let's get him high.
You know he will do some funny shit,
you know? No, that's what I want.
When I wrote down,
when she said I wrote the up in smoke,
that's exactly what I had mine.
In fact, every movie I did,
I said I'm not going to waste a bit of
screen time on anything unless it has to
do with with part.
And then we got offered a Corsican
brothers and teach at that time.
She was ready to split, he was
ready to leave and chief says, well,
I don't want to do another pot
Moby, you know, so I said, well,
why don't we just make this
one a new one part movie? Okay.
So we did no part in it at all. And
it's a lot of people's favorite movies,
you know?
But we,
we reached a point where just being
Cheech and John was all we needed to be.
Right. You know, we didn't,
we didn't have to smoke a joint or
anything and that's the way it is. Yeah.
That's the way it is now.
Like when I get introduced,
it's like a title, you know, this
is Tommy Chong of Cheech and Chong.
Do you still ever run into
people that don't want to,
like especially professional people that
don't want to be associated with pot?
Uh, actors, uh, slow.
Yeah. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a shitload of pimp. Depends on
which way the wind's blowing, you know?
But with me, Oh yeah, there's, there's,
oh, listen to Saturday night live.
Ever wonder why Cheech and Chong,
I'd never hosted Saturday night live.
Was that boring? Michael? Does not like
Cheech and Chong. Really? Why does he not?
Does he conservative?
We came up when Ackroyd and Belushi and
Belushi marry together and Ackroyd and
Belushi caused, it caused him so much
grief, but he couldn't fire because
they were, they were the
stars. Right. And, but he, he,
he never had control of those guys.
And Belushi was a big Chong,
Cheech and Chong Fan. Big Time.
And I guess Akroyd was too,
but Belushi was, he was, he was
like a fan. Right, right. Great.
From the get go. He did, he started, in
fact, he was with second city and he kept,
they were trying to do an album because
teaching chunk done at home. Right.
And bluejay and the producing kept
saying this to Cheech and Chong to,
Geez, that's funny. Yeah.
They recently had a parody of you guys
on Saturday night did this lab and that
kind of Kent County got me because why
didn't they have us? Right. I mean we,
we were available. What was the party?
Can you play it? Uh, what's his name? Um,
is this it Brian? Yeah, I think it. What's
a, what's the code? The quarterback.
The one last year. Uh, brother, I dunno.
Manny, one of the
Manning's. Peyton manning?
No, for their irreverence.
Pop drug healer.
The past start in several feature films
throughout the 1970s but did you know
that Cheech and Chong and actually
had a third member? It's true tonight.
We show you that original cuts of
their films with the original lineup.
Let's take a look at 1978 up in smoke.
You want to get to the concert?
Even if we got speed. Speed.
Did you guys see Donny and
Marie last night? It was, Ooh,
I didn't to speak with me.
I may speak for that speed
like cousin back home in a lot more.
That runs on Maui wowie
story.
Sometimes I can't even tell if you teach.
Hey, did I tell you guys
who's in town? Greg Taylor.
Remember I told you about him?
He and I went to camp together
and then just get those days pass.
No thanks.
No, I better not friends. I have a
scholarship to Indiana University.
I could not be around drugs.
Would you mind pulling over? Yeah,
sure thing right up here is great.
Thanks.
You return then go by Richard.
Millions of that was funny.
Yeah.
Why did they use teaching chart? Yeah.
Well they can use it for something else,
but you wouldn't work for that because
they would have to go back in time. Yeah,
no, that's true. But I mean,
I think just out of
respect for the culture,
you know, they should have had us on
there once. Never went. That's ridiculous.
How dare he, I mean they'll know is a
Britney spears, it'll have all these,
you know, Peyton manning
or whatever. In my opinion,
that show is always to missed
two for me to give it enough.
There's some hits for sure. Yeah. But
it's so, you know, it's hit and miss,
but so much mass that I'm not willing to
invest any time into it. Yeah, it's hard.
It's the hardest form of entertainment
to do a live sort of a sketch comedy show
once a week.
It's such a crapshoot as to whether or
not things are going to actually be funny.
Well, they've got no time. They've
got no time to make it funny. Yeah.
So I got an idea. We don't
have time. Yeah. Yeah.
They have to hustle through things and
some things get passed. You're like,
fuck that.
I'm thinking what's going on there.
But that's what kind of bothered me.
You know,
when we started doing
concerts lately, um, some,
some of the concerts when I started,
when I got Kinda got back into the
music a hot second and it was called the
music speed, you know, rock is all about,
okay, you guys, you've got 15 minutes,
get on, let's go. This, it got it. Some
backstage goof, you know, telling you,
oh yeah, hurry up, hurry up, hurry
up. We got to, what, why were you,
why would they telling you
when to do it? Or like, well,
it shows me you had other people
with you, the, you know, yeah.
Either acts going on.
Oh,
so they're trying to get everybody
on it and then certain certain acts,
if there's stars during their trailer,
they're not coming out. Right. But,
but any act they can bullet, you know,
then you would, I just didn't see,
there's like music festivals. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. This is a few years ago,
I got both my sons,
one's a bass player,
wins a drummer and I put a little
thing together, you know, movies,
their music bit together.
There's just the three of us and it
was good for one summer, you know,
a lot of fun. But the music,
you know, it's, it's uh,
you know, we, we one thing about
comedy, you know, we, we command,
you know, we're out there. It's our stage,
you know, I don't like to share on stage.
Well, it's hard when you have a vision
of what you want to accomplish and then
somebody else does and then
do the key to being in a band,
I guess is figure out how to compromise
and making as many people happy as
possible while still getting out some
fragment or portion of your creative
vision. But it's certainly much easier to
get out of your full creative vision by
herself. But I love it. I love it. You
know, I thought about it, you know, now,
especially now, cause I
got Cheech, no, you know,
we finished our touring in that and so
I was playing around with the idea of,
you know, putting a band together.
I think about it a hassle.
In fact, I'd rather just drop
down, you know, I like to,
when you know Shelby and over there
alone or being alone, you know,
I don't mind that at all. They're
like, yeah, it's, it's a lot easier to,
to do whatever you want to do.
I'm going to answer to anybody mind trips.
That's what you're doing with people.
Like I put the sweat lodge in the
show and the first time I did it,
this club owner came running backstage
and screaming at my wife, you know,
what's he doing?
What's he doing?
He's been talking about
rocks for 15 minutes.
The club owner was yelling at your
wife. Where was this? This is Craig.
Uh, Kansas City. Oh, that
crazy. Fuck yeah. Beetle juice.
Yeah. You're doing it as a real
character math. What's he doing up there?
He's talking about
rocks. Yeah. Great. Okay.
Sounds it does sound like beetle juice,
doesn't it?
Well that's the kind of club to dates I
did when I was in the Denver man when I
was in Denver. I don't know. I don't even
remember smoking. I don't think I did.
I did five shows and not
one was like the other.
I did five totally different shows.
How come I just couldn't do it. You just
kind of got the audience going. Yeah.
Denver as a Stoney town. Once
I got them going, I just never,
never got back onto the script.
Right. And then when my wife and I,
which we do a set bit,
when we hit the set bit,
we literally got standing ovations.
Really? Yeah. Wow. How was,
I was so great as tiny. And then we
sold merchants and met everybody.
It was like old age.
Wow.
Cause it was a time when we used to
bring a case of bongs but their shit on
selling. So what I did, I
sold these uh, not a pipes.
Those things. Yeah, yeah, yeah. The
necklaces. I had grabbed a bunch.
I don't know, something told
me. Yeah. Take it. You know,
because we're going up with Cheech
is, was funding everything, you know,
but confined,
it's Cheech and Chong.
Do you find it that there's certain
spots in the country where you're more a
welcomed or the connected you or
they're there the more into pot humor?
Yeah. Well Denver for sure.
For sure. Right. Amber,
Denver isn't marijuana decriminalize? Yep.
In the city. And then they have their,
they have a medical marijuana, so they
have dispensary's. There's some, I think,
I don't know if they call it
[inaudible] or damn or what,
but there's a whole street,
they even got a system of, um, uh,
what do you call it?
Naming the clubs. You know,
like this is a, B and c I
guess. Oh, you mean like,
like rating the rating them? Yeah.
Really. Like the town has the rating.
Dispensary. Yeah. Yeah, man.
There it's very accepted there.
It's a fucking great town.
I love Colorado, man.
I'm not going back there August 10th.
I think I've got a show in Denver,
whatever that Friday is. Uh, I
can't wait to get back there. This,
I think there's something, it's
my opinion. But when you're,
when you grow up in a place
like Denver where it's a city,
but it's also in face of some of
the most staggering mother nature.
Not like when you look at those
mountains, the rocky mountains, sorry,
mother fucker.
And if you're in Denver,
like I remember we were at a
radio station wants, we were just,
it was like high a up in this office
building and we're sitting there on the
20th floor or whatever the fuck it was.
Looking out there and you see the
rocky mountains like God damn son.
Well did you ever get tired of looking
at that? That's the goddamn rocky
mountains I grew up in Calgary,
so both the rocky mountain,
I think when you see
mountains and shit like that,
I think it puts you in a more
mellow sort of a, a place humbling.
Yeah, it puts you in proportion.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The ocean goes the same
thing. Yeah, the desert. Yeah.
I don't know if that does it as much as
makes you want to fuck people to death
and brought them up and
leave them in a hole.
All the wars are being fought in the
desert. So it sucks there. You know,
I watched this thing and the Taliban, when
the Taliban shot some woman, you know,
cause they accused her of adultery and
all I could think of is this, this,
this whole situation sucks where
they live, sucks. The weather sucks.
The culture sucks to soul
situation. Sucks. Mine.
This would not happen if
it was Brazil and Brazil.
You know that you don't
accuse a woman of adultery.
You just deal with it and move on.
Bitch.
Cause it what girls are hot as fuck and
they're everywhere. It's get over it.
But in Afghanistan it's
such a fucking struggle.
Well it's because of the inbreeding.
I think maybe it's also because that's
where the oldest culture comes from. Yeah.
I mean it's a bit like the townies
of the world is what it's like.
You have everything started there.
Mesopotamia, Babylon, Iraq who mayor.
That's what they think.
They think that everything started there.
If that's where the beaten. Yeah. Well if
that was real, right, whatever that is.
The analogy of that is,
but that from that is where they wrote,
it has where the those,
where the stories came stories.
They also had stories that supposedly to
come from even earlier that there were
like retold. So you know, but,
but my point is like that's
the spot where it all began.
Everybody agrees to that.
So if that's a spot where it all began,
but it's still there. We're
writing, we're mathematics,
agriculture writing. I mean that's, that's
how we got the great buildings in her.
It was all thanks to
the Arabs. Yeah, sure.
Persian Algebra or Algebra.
Now the Arabs and the Muslims in general,
I mean came up with some amazing
discoveries. It's just, it's,
what's going on now is this
radical offshoot of it, you know,
that seems to have been accepted and they,
they backed everybody in the corner where
if you accept Islam at all, you know,
you have to be on the side of
these radical motherfuckers. Like,
cause this is like there's this,
there's this connection in a lot of
people's minds to that, you know,
that we don't even see Muslims.
We just see radical Muslims.
It's all anybody sees and like this is
a religion that will not stop until this
happens and it just,
it becomes this weird form of
brainwashing on our part and almost like
reinforcing reality on their part.
The more we talk about them willing to
blow themselves up, guaranteeing you,
the more they're willing
to blow themselves up.
The more we were talking about
how terrified we are of that,
the more they're going to employ
those tactics. Absolutely.
That's the whole secret
life is like a a workout. If you
look at the way to say, Oh God,
that's heavy. Oh, I'll
never be able to do that.
You're not going to be able to work out.
Right? But if you walk in there and go,
Whoa, that's going to help me.
You know what Bible translation
is? The universe does not like
bitches. That's what it is.
Do Universe frowns upon bitches.
That's what it is.
The universe doesn't want you gotta. You
gotta get get your shit together, bitch.
There's a right way every minute of
every day you're taking a decision.
You're making you carving a path and
choosing to say certain things and go
certain places and asked her in ways, you
know, you know which way you could go.
Why,
what it is is a better way
vibe to see people don't really realize
the kind of vibe they're putting out.
You know, that's why the pedophiles
and that, you know, you know,
they've had a fucked up life until
they were pursuing it out there.
But for some reason you get a crowd
of people and all of a sudden you can,
there's one weird or in there the vibe.
Oh yeah. Well one angry heckler could
fuck up a whole crowd of 300 people.
Have you ever had that happen?
One person just angry for no reason
yelling at you and you're like,
why is going on with you man?
Like idiot.
Sometimes it can be
about something you say.
Like I some woman got Super Mad Cause
I was doing this joke about that.
The idea being that you shouldn't,
there's a big difference
between having a man, uh,
molesting a young girl or young boy
and a woman molesting a young boy.
Because if a chick's hot, like if a
woman is hot, we barely care. You know,
you barely care if you hear that,
like some seven year old got,
if you walked in and there was a seven
year old getting blown by like the
hottest girl in the world.
And he was like, you know,
like raising his fist
and triumph. And I, uh,
I saw this woman go, that's it. That's
it. And she gets up and she's like,
fuck this, I'm not listening to this.
This is fucking terrible. It's disgusting.
And as she was saying,
she's like walking through the club,
just like poisoning the atmosphere,
the club.
I got lucky that I turned it
into a pot. I was like, listen,
I just want to point
out that there was no,
this is a work of fiction and no real
babies were blowing during the making of
any of this material. So I started going
on this explanation about it. You know,
Stephen King Movie, Carrie can light
things on fire with her eyes, right?
But you're telling me that some seven
year old kid wouldn't like getting his
dick sucked in my fiction. That's
much more likely. It's very,
very, very touchy because
a lot of people probably,
she's probably went through some,
some weird,
a lot of people. I think a lot
of people, I think, you know,
I dodged a bullet twice in my youth
from being molested once when I was like
eight and once when I was
like 13 I dodged two bullets.
I got to think a lot of people get hit.
A lot of people get fragged.
Well, I, I got well kind of molested
when I was learning how to swim.
Really?
They had free swimming lessons at
the Ymc a the only problem was,
or the only thing was that we didn't
need bathing suits. Oh, Jesus Christ.
There were literally 2020
young guys with no baby.
Oh my God. Women learn
how to swim. Oh my God.
And when the YMC guys were
okay, one more time. Oh my God.
Hey boys are there again? Okay. No, you're
doing good. So he's just watching you.
Was he touching? No, no. Just, just,
just wash it. Teaching you how to swim.
He asshole. But, but what was, I mean,
why do you stand behind the podium and
beat off or you guys are swimming and
never really see at the time, you
know, you don't. You don't. Yeah,
you're totally, you're busy. Yeah. Yeah.
And then then another time I was,
I would've never got really hit on it.
I was playing basketball
at the Y in Hollywood and
there's a locker room there.
No, this is a New York.
It's a New York City and there's
a locker and this guy comes up.
You went to
catch a buzz later and looked around
to see who was talking to you.
He said, no, you, I'm talking to you.
Do you want to catch a buzz later?
I says,
I don't think so.
And then he reaches into his locker and
pulls up the sickest pair of glasses
I've ever seen. He puts some on,
he looks at me goes, oh, nevermind.
I'm sorry. Oh, that's
hilarious. Do you think that is?
He thought you were someone else or he
found out what you're really looked like
and he's like, damn, I
can do better than this.
He's like, I'm not ready to
cash in my tag this early.
I'm still going to go out hunting.
I think that's what it was.
Oh, sorry. Wrong, wrong, wrong guy.
So how often are you going out and
doing stand up now and if so, how?
How can people see you?
We got one more gig again. The Ice
House. You should do the ice house.
You ever do the Ice House to show started
here? Did you really? Yeah. Wow. Yeah.
Bugs dangerous to come.
You never paid us.
They paid us all he did pay us.
Wasn't much 50 bucks I think for,
for both of us.
This is back in 1970 70
so was 50 bucks worth back then it
was like 100 bucks. 500 bucks. Yeah,
it was a lot of money was, it
was 50 bucks. I'm trying to,
trying to put it in perspective.
Well, we weren't working right.
What was it worth today like with
the inflation? Was He what was gay?
I don't know. Could you say
like a couple hundred bucks?
Five bucks, five? No, no, no.
What was it? Oh, so it's five times
more. Yeah. Okay, so 250 bucks. Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
And so every time you work you got to
eat and pay rent and all that shit.
The little bit of rent and
a little bit of what was,
I got a month's rent an apartment back
then we said Lily Tomlin used to come and
try out all their material
here. Oh really? Uh,
Stamitus Steve Martin work yesterday.
Mark David Letterman's contract is
on the wall from him working here.
He,
he got pissed off at teaching job
because after we made it, we made a big,
we mentioned every club but the ice, I was
immediate mentioned the ice house.
Forgot about it.
Fucking Pasadena man.
We, we the Troubadour, we mentioned
the troubadour view other clubs.
This is my favorite club in the
country. And then, then the ISOS,
I mean comedy wise we, we, we killed
he, he had a clean policy for years.
Did it really? Oh that's hilarious.
Cause now Joey Diaz does every Wednesday.
Whom do you know? Joey D is? Joey
D. He's a good friend of ours.
He's a podcast all the time.
Stand up comedian Cuban guy. Oh,
I'm thinking of Nick Diaz is a fighter.
A fighter. I know it is. Yeah. No,
Joey Diaz is probably the funniest
guy in the planet. Is He? Yeah, he's,
my friend does been friends
with him for like 10 years.
I don't know anybody who makes me laugh.
One that guy more than 10 years. Shit.
Me and genuine friends like 15. And he
is stand up. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's hilarious. Ridiculous. We're
dateless pot at two. Oh, of course.
Every day he's going to start doing,
Joey's going to start doing
a new Ustream show, uh,
two or three days a week by himself at
six o'clock in the morning cause he gets
up at six and he smokes weed and listens
to music and then he goes for a walk
and I'll go to this dispensary,
you know,
bias weed and he's going to document
it all on Ustream. So every morning,
you know how many days a week he chooses
to do this is going to do it at least
twice. He says he's going to get up at
six o'clock in the morning. He goes,
I'm gonna put on a fucking lecture
for these cocksuckers is how he talks.
He doesn't want to play them the right
music. I want to get that Ustream working.
He goes every day. Fuck
it. I'm up. Anyway, I'm up
anyway. Six o'clock and went,
got Baba. Just going to start there. And
he works here all the time. Oh yeah. Yeah,
all the time. What's, which
is hilarious. He's so dirty.
He's like one of the dirtiest guys ever.
And he's like a regular
here while staying.
Oh Bob.
At first gen they literally told them
and then all the street lamp in people,
you know, they would come and make an
appearance here. Right. And it was very,
very straight.
That's funny.
Well Times change.
Well Cheech and Chong, well we did our
active, you know, we never held back.
Did anybody ever tried to censor
you? Not really good. Lately,
lately we were at a casino in Biloxi,
Mississippi,
Mississippi. And I'm just about to do
the show, you know, doing a sound check.
Got My son a working the roadie and
we're setting the mix up in that.
And then the guy comes over,
he's old, by the way. Um,
just want to remind you that,
you know, the chief, uh, uh,
really religious and so you got
to really watch your language.
We looked at him. What is it?
Yeah, you got to go. I said,
well what happens if we don't? These
was, he could pull the plug on you. He,
he'd been known to do that.
Wow. So just, wow. Okay.
So then, uh, I went and told changing,
or the guy came in the dressing room.
I told [inaudible] it says, teacher,
the guy who wants us to do a clean show.
And she says, fuck that man. The wounds.
What motherfucking was to do a clean job.
Tell me, is this a mother fucker? Fuck
that I ain't doing no fucking clean joke.
What happened? He knew she
was joking. Well, what we did,
we cut down my wives show cause
she, she, she gets a little,
a little out there. She gets graphic. Well
she gets a little out there, you know,
that would, that would piss him
off. You know, Cheech and Chong,
we never did anything. So it's a sexual
thing he's worried about? No, it was,
it was just, uh, the, the, what do
you call them? The producer. Right,
right. But what was the content that they
were worried about? Was it bad words?
Bad words. Wait, what it was,
he's sucking up to the chief.
You know what it was.
He never told the chief when Cheech
and Chong and really what a CNA.
Now at the last moment,
last more he knew.
But then when chief didn't know that today
I guess I had a fucking UBA chief and
not know who Cheech and Chong
is. Well how dairy. But anyway,
we uh,
it never heard,
although cheat you did one leader
is that Jesus did do one, uh,
one bit where we're, a couple of
people got up and left. Really? Yeah.
What was it that was his is favored a
director and he turned out to be Roman
Polanski. Rodriguez. Paul Rodriguez.
I know Robert. Robert Rodriguez.
Robert Rodriguez. Cause he had great
dialogue in his movie. Pussy, Bluesy,
bluesy got got hairy pussy.
No Fuzzy, hairy, you know,
rice, all fuzzy, fuzzy, yellow
Posey, any kind of pussy.
Get it right here. That was it. A
couple of pussies got up. We've heard,
it's funny how people in
comedy clubs want to change.
Want to change your act when they like
tune, they want to drive the car. Yeah,
they didn't. They just want
to have it over you. Sure.
They don't like the fact that
you're getting all the attention.
The worst is when you get booked into
a club and then once you get to go,
especially if you're like, when I was,
you know, I was like middling. I couldn't,
it wasn't really making real money and
I would get sent to these clubs in the
middle of nowhere and you would get
there and they would have like their own
standards they impose on you.
I'll get off stage.
I don't know if anybody talked
to you about the language,
but you can't talk like that.
I'm like,
you better fucking fire me because this
is what I'm doing because what I do,
there's only one way to make an audience.
Okay.
And it's the get people to come back
and see you and you gotta do what you
actually do. Cause you know, if you
pretend that I got booked with my act,
there's Max, I'm going to
do it. So there was like a,
she had to call the booking agent
and the booking agent. I was like,
that's what I booked. And this
is a, you know, it's like,
and she was just in a manager,
just a manager that decided that she
was going to be a sensor. It wasn't,
her name was Connie. No,
somewhere in New York. It was, um,
it was one of those fucking Kong Island.
How many clubs in the middle of nowhere?
I don't even remember where it was.
What part of the article was one
of those weird little shitty clubs.
But that's the thing that a lot of comics
have to go through this club owners,
you know, they don't want mean,
you don't want to take a chance.
I have some asshole coming or run all
your customers out. But it's foul humor.
Well,
I mean you gotta to listen your homework.
Find out who your booking on that side.
Exactly. I gave them a tape. The tape
had the same material that I was doing.
He backed down. That's how you'd
get it. You'd have to get a god up,
make a VHS tape yet.
But he could make copies of it with two
VHS recorders connected together and you
always had a friend who knew how to do
that and you can edit it and it was,
the edits are terrible and it was like
a big fuzzy pause in between sets that
you did in different places.
So He'd send it out to a club and they go,
oh that guy's got a good act.
All right, I'll book them.
And that's how you got work. You'd
have to send tapes out. We'd,
there'll be a big part of your job trying
to get go places and sent tapes out
when,
when you guys
were we had, we had albums that
we send out. That's what we did.
That's what it was. That's what got
people to come and see. You guys.
Did you have to do radio or
anything back from those guys?
I still do radio to let people
know in town. I love doing radio.
How often are you on Twitter? She
doesn't like. I try to be every day.
But she doesn't like radio and,
no. No. How come? He's his lazy.
He's lazy. Is that what it is? Basically.
Does he like acting more than the former?
[inaudible] he loves getting paid. Know.
Just talk. Pretend sitting around. Yeah.
Is that what it is?
He doesn't,
he's not a threat to them
and see or anybody. Oh,
stage. Yeah. I'm not even
sure what that means.
So he doesn't like, he's not,
he's not like going up on
weeknights and working on,
no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no. In fact
he never, he never, he, he went out.
What did he do? He went out and Mcu the
Latin kings of comedy. Right, right.
That's about it.
What was the,
did you ever ask him what it was like
working with Don Johnson fellows years.
Little bit. I've heard of it. Dot.
I got a different, we've got a,
we're got to walk on tip toes
around him. Oh really? Yeah.
Is it because you guys
just worked together for so
long and just know there is
few bad decisions made that we don't,
you know, when, when we broke up the,
the, the bond was broken, you know,
I mean, no, I mean there's still
memories, you know, it's almost like a,
like an ex wife, you know, get together
for the kids. Right. That's weird, man.
What, what, what drove you guys apart?
Was it ego? Was it money was, no,
it was fear of not working.
I think.
Fear of not working. Yeah. Well,
Cheech, soon as he got offered,
offered something on his own,
he took it.
Was it that or was that just he
didn't want it to be independent,
wanting to be able to make his own money.
I think a lot of it,
he didn't like the fact that
I was the Alpha Dog. You were,
the guy wrote every saying,
well, I directed for sure.
I direct it and a lot of decisions,
I made all the decisions, you know,
I wonder the decisions I made.
Uh,
we got offered a big
television contract back in the
back in the day, you know, and
I turned it down, you know,
the big money, you know, I, I don't know
how I did it, but I did it. I just said,
well, what are they trying to get
you to do? It was on a sitcom. Well,
it ended up being Chico in the man.
In fact,
there was one that Chico and the man was
one of our bits. Whoa. Jimmy Coleman.
Jimmy carmax followed us
around for four months.
Chico and the man was one of
your bits. Yeah. How did it
go? What was it like? Well,
we did a bit called old man in the park
and the Chicano would come up with a
comb. Yeah. Real tough guy.
And the old guy and him would have
a little argument, you know, and uh,
I would,
I would insult them.
Pretty soon I just copied that and turned
it into what he did. He got an old man,
Albert Chico. Freddie, Freddie Prinze,
and they turned it into a sitcom.
Yeah.
For folks who don't know,
Freddie prints for one small but brief
moment in time was one of the biggest
stars in the country.
We see huge television star.
Huge one crazy and committed
suicide. Yeah. Yeah.
And then he tried to show without them.
And that's one of the reasons that, that,
um,
that I turned down and television
because I don't like losing control.
Right. I found nothing works. If
I don't have control of something,
we don't sell anything and nothing works.
What's not going to be your vision?
It's going to be someone's idea
of what your relationship be. It,
it's not the same thing.
You know what it is. It's,
it's someone's vision that doesn't
have a, an offer, you know,
it's a production company that goes,
Hey,
I got a great idea right you
to teach you you're this.
And they're the ones who put up the money.
So they want, they want money and that,
uh,
and,
and we tried to sell a bunch of stuff
lately and no one's interested in.
Yeah. I mean, because Noah's a is the
best filter in this town, you know,
just say no.
And if the guy wants a bad Nuffield,
we'll keep at it until you say yes.
But when they see nobody Cheech
and Chong and it's like, oh, okay,
next let's go somewhere else. And you
guys are icons, you know together.
You guys doing a comedy show is a no fail.
It's like if you are a respectable stoner
and Cheech and Chong coming in Denver,
you got to go see them. But what we
have to do, like if it's on television,
we can't have it watered down.
CanNot be, why go on television.
Just stick with the Internet man.
Do something like this shot Ustream show
you guys fucking fill arenas everyday
of the week. You do do a like a
youtube show or used to didn't you?
Or like a like a blog type video.
Yeah, I did. I did a lot of that. Yeah.
I that those were really interesting.
And you stopped doing them or yeah,
well we went on tour and then I
couldn't get, the mics were good.
Oh, that's hilarious. And
you know, we don't have a,
my son actually set it up and we
start off with what are you doing?
Your podcast out of my house.
You're going to do it out of your house.
Are you setting up like a studio then?
Yeah, I got it set up. It's all set.
Ready to go. I'm just waiting
to wait til September. Oh,
well my son gets back in or you want to
do it with him? I'm going to wait until
he gets back and then kind of build up.
Build up the anticipation. The
anticipation. That's a good idea.
You're clever looking at
you. You marketing genius.
We never thought about that.
He just started at, uh,
just fucking goofing on it.
I've never even tried to promote this
time. This things became this by itself.
But you could tell like, look where
it is or room. What do you need?
How many clubs? Yeah, that's all you do.
Need Room with fucking cool shit
on the wall and some mannequins.
Look like Brian's ex girlfriend. A toilet
in a toilet that flushes and zombies.
Yeah. By the way, we're
getting up at day here. Dude,
we're getting one of those electronic
crazy things. I'll, when it all happened,
I mentioned on the podcast,
it's a um,
a company that is offered to send us
one of those cool Japanese butthole
cleaning time. So sites, those are
main was in Tokyo in the bathroom.
I couldn't get out of
all the wonderful heat.
It squirts water rate in your asshole
and you just don't want to get up.
You just beat off.
Did you know I just sat there for like
10 minutes just letting it just do that.
Yeah. I beat off once, once during
the week and it was fantastic.
Great warm water tickling your
butthole. UHHH. Why is that so terrible?
Is it, how could it be so bad? I feel
so good. That's what I have to say.
What the Japanese are
into the claims ledger to,
they feel like you've figured out a lot
of shit about martial arts too and they
make a bad ass car.
Yeah.
They are super clean people like they
just like get eight to take showers,
multiple times evolved.
They evolved on a totally different
line than western America.
It's very fascinating to me.
When I look at Japanese culture and I
think it's amazing the Samurai culture,
the fact that there's so many martial
arts, I, Kido, Jujitsu, karate,
all these different things come
out of Japan, you know, so,
so much comes out of Japan, so it's an
amazing place. Well, Japan, the Japan,
we'll take it and refine it. They'll take
somebody else's. I like martial arts.
We took it from India cars.
They'll refine it into something.
The Prius. I drive a Prius. All my
friends, how dare you, you hippie.
[inaudible] hippie. Yeah. The
everybody loves those things.
Here's a perfect, don't give a shit about
a car. A car you can have, you know,
just there it is.
It's a car.
It gets me from here to
there and it easy on gas.
And you can put those in
the sound like the Mustang.
You know what I'm talking about?
Tommy Chong and you fire up a
Shelby gt 500 and you hit that.
You can shift your own gears. You fucking
fucking man again when the trouble is,
all you see in your future
is traffic school. Yeah.
You know you can't be an asshole with it.
But even just regular driving when you
drive a car like a Mustang, I tried to
customize my Prius and so I change
the exhaust. Had it lowered,
I heavily headed on a hydraulics,
hydraulics.
Wouldn't that defeat the whole purpose
all the way to the hydraulics and make
the gas mileage terrible? No,
no. Forget gas. I had dual pipes.
I had the, did you really have all
this stuff? I haven't really had it.
I had the tail lights blacked out.
You been murdered? That bitch.
And then I ended up getting arrested or
getting a ticket really for everything.
Well for the tail lights for sure.
And then I had to go to court and
the guy was a fan and he says,
well come back at one o'clock you know?
And so I come back and when I thought,
you know the judges coming back,
we'll see. Thank you. Goodbye.
I had a stand up front of the thing.
How do you plead and get a
tech to get a $10 fine to him?
Yeah.
$10 wait for everybody.
$10 because your car had tinted,
uh,
brake lights is that
silly picture. So, so I,
I just took it right back to what it was.
And what word statement?
Well, was it better looking once
he falls? It was phenomenal.
It looks so good because I could
lower it right onto the ground.
Have you ever seen the Lotus car that they
made out of? Yeah. Yeah. The hamp Lotus,
I think, no, I don't even want,
they showed pictures of it on this podcast
before Lotus made a call. By the way,
the first car, you know,
that was made at a Hamp,
Henry Ford had body panels,
made it a ham and his videos of
him hitting it with a hammer. Yeah.
And it bounces up.
People don't really believe like half
the Shit I say because obviously no
scientist and I'm half retarded.
But if you just watch some of the video,
so what, what's capable and
possible with the, the hemp that's,
that's constructed into body panels.
It's amazing that they don't
do it today to this day.
Well they had the electric car too.
I wonder how much it would cost to get,
this is a good question. I'm going to
put this out there to the universe.
How much would it cost to get a corvette
and replace all those fiberglass body
panels with hemp and have it in
the exact same shape? I don't know.
I would be willing to struggle.
I can make you do it. Please.
I'd be willing to spend a lot of money
that go to the can and take a leak and
then we'll come back and wrap this up.
Oh,
can I just want to thank everyone that
came to that Doug Benson taping that we
did the other day.
It was,
I mean they people pride all of garden
bread sticks to me and people stoled
olive garden menus and sensory David List.
But I'll phone was Vegas.
Oh this great. How Fun was dice dice that,
that, that was another thing I forgot.
Completely forgot about that.
We went to go see dice and I was really
kind of in the back of my head thinking,
all right, this is not going
to be as good. I don't think
I, you know, I, I, I just,
I don't know.
It's for some reason I just didn't think
like he was going to be as good as in
my head. Well I'm just being honest,
but he, I understand you'd be not,
he blew me.
I wait.
Oh you been think I was
going to be good fucking guy.
His jokes per minute like he is, he's
just like Bam, Bam, Bam, Bam, Bam.
Both here for red crew, whatever the
fuck his name is. This cock sucker. No,
I mean like there were certain
people you're, you're, you know,
after a while you're like, I wonder if
they still have it and you know, and,
and that's just what I kind of thought.
Never doubted for a, yeah, we would have
never done,
I've always been a dice clay fan watching
when I used to work at the comedy
store story.
So loved,
watch them get angry and yell at people
and put like Heelys dice mean, you know,
he keeps the big set up to this day.
Cause I was say I love what dice mean
comes out cause he was fucking torture
people. And he's in character, so
there's shitty says it's so crazy.
That's his character is,
in my opinion,
one of the funniest characters
in the history of comedy.
And a lot of people misunderstand.
A lot of people get mad at him and say
it that don't ask is misogynism this is
racism. This is, this is, this
is how he really thinks you're,
you couldn't be further from the truth.
You couldn't be more wrong.
He's a combination of reality and fiction.
He's a Schumann walking amalgam edge.
But what does it work? Amalgamated them.
Knock on them quickly.
Amalgamated them. No.
What does the word Amalgam eyes when
he amalgamates what does the hell,
what the hell is the word? Human Amalgam
in them. No, that's not the word.
You're using two bigger words.
Yeah. Well, whatever it is,
he's a combination of reality
and his creation. He's,
he's dice clay. He, and when
you watch them, you understand.
If you go and watch like a full, like hour
set, he doesn't mean what he's saying.
Aye. I, we came backstage after the
show and he goes, this dice clay.
We came backstage after the show and
he was so happy that we're there.
It was because it came with,
uh,
Jim Norton and Anthony Kamiya
from opiate and Claudia and Kelly,
Robert Kelly and Bryan. It's Sam
Roberts. And so we all came backstage.
We're telling them how great it was
and everything. He was so happy,
but he was like, he'll, teal tells
you his formula. He goes, he goes,
I do know research. He goes,
I'm rob about everything I say,
but I say it with such conviction,
you know, he knows what he's doing.
I guess it's this creation and it was
fucking awesome. We had a great time.
That was some of the hardest, I've
laughed at to stand up comedy in a while.
He's got that great New York
attitude. It's an attitude.
Yeah. Well he's perfected
the gangsters, goofy, the gangsters
tapes, you know, they'll do it every time.
I remember one time I was in Banff where
to some conventions or zone and the
mountains and beautiful that. And then
when, when, where's the record of Banff,
Alberta?
It's in the rocky mountains,
like timber in the middle of the
ski area and we're standing outside.
The New York guy looked,
he ain't nature at cocksucker.
I bet it was Joey Diaz.
He's never been to Canada.
That's it. That is what a guy
from New York would say too.
Yeah. There's that, that style
of humor. There's really not,
not like anywhere else. That New York
attitude, it's a very different sort of,
it's endearing to a certain extent.
Irritating and retarded, you know,
for the most part. But there's parts
of it, like when dice nails it,
that's so endearing.
That's the greatest thing about it
is that it was really fun. Funny.
I loved this man and you know,
when he did the movie
sad.
Oh God, he wasn't good. He had
such a shot yet I shot. Yeah.
But all he had to do was get a dice clay
to directed in the right. Right, right.
So all we needed was also while
the protests were going on,
people are protesting exact women's
group or protesting gay. No,
but you can't go backwards. You
know, you can't take that shit. Yeah.
Take, what you got to do is make him
your friend like you do, you know. Well,
he didn't have,
they didn't have the Internet back then.
So you needed someone to put
you in something you needed
to, someone to, you know,
unless you were doing just concerts. But
I mean he had it. He's a good actor. Yeah,
fine. After I saw him in another
movie, a little low budget movie.
And you played a serious role. That's
why he's such a good comic. He's got,
he's got performance chops. Tiny. Yeah.
Yeah. He's been timing. Great timing.
It was really fun.
We saw him at the Riviera,
which is also like stepping into a time
capsule because the Riviera has photos
on the wall from the 1950 [inaudible].
This is the Vegas. He the top of the roof.
Yeah, the, the theater at the top.
Yeah. He does a bunch of shows there.
Apparently it does all the time. I worked
there with my wife. Oh, did you? Yeah.
The Shelby is Shelby.
You know, she, she's uh,
I am Benatar basically. Right. You know,
she had never been on stage
and you made her get onstage.
I'm wondering to come on the road with
me, you know, and she goes, I said,
I'll put you in the show because she
was taken acting and so she's okay right
away, you know, you're
very job, she'll do it. So,
so she did five minutes to an introduce
me. Did you write her material? Oh,
quite a bit of her stuff, you know, and
I got her, got her going and got her.
She's doing good now. She's now, she's
happening, you know. And so we're,
we're doing club after club and we're
doing really good and people loving her in
that. And so we get, we get
gigged a book was Bobcat,
Bobcat, Goldthwait, bobcat, Goldthwait.
Bobcat had just dumped,
it just dumped his wife for a young girl.
And Shelby mentioned,
mentioned it in her show,
like she's just doing her show
and she said, oh yeah, bobcat, no,
you've got the new way. Yeah,
that's something blah, blah, blah.
Bobcat almost had a miscarriage.
He literally crying to me crying in tears.
Did you hear what your wife said to me
and I looked down at my, this
is the top of the rib. I said,
am I in the wrong club or something?
You know, this is a comedy club.
That's what you do. This is what
you do. It's just a new wife. Right?
Why is that bad?
Why is it bad to have a new wife if you're
in love with someone doing enough to
marry him? What it was? Why is it bad?
What it was is that bobcat has a number
of really considered himself a comic.
What? No, he, he's, he's a movie
director or something, you know,
but he's never really considered himself,
but he was for a long time.
He did his act, but it was
a character, you know, that.
Sure. He still does stand
up and now he's doubly does.
I think he got over that
character and now he does himself.
He had him on the podcast.
He actually, no, no, he's,
he's very talented and all that.
He cried like a,
like a little fucking baby. You
know? Any want of me? What do,
what do you want me to
do? Well, what year?
What year was this in the 90s he
hadn't gotten on the Internet yet.
He was a baby. Like all of us may
be children of the Times. Yeah.
I mean, we all needed to be educated
as, I mean, you get, you get sensitive,
you know, in a comedy club. I mean,
and anybody else, you know, you,
you take your right here,
hits with everybody else,
you know. That is true. Yeah.
Yeah. But he was in Craig, especially at
a comedy. Craig was there. Same place.
No, no. This was in the, in
Vegas. At the river. At the
top of them. And he was there.
It crazy killing hookers.
He came with some weird chick.
Yeah.
But the bobcat and Bobcat
was, oh, he was, he was,
he was so mad. Well, some,
some comics do where their heart in
the sleeve as a lot of us that got into
comedy because we're fucked
up in the first place. That's
a big percentage. Yeah.
So I give them a Mulligan for the nineties
I really enjoyed having
him on the podcast too.
Although I still have not seen God bless
America. You see get prime. No, I haven't.
Which one? He just directed a new
movie. That's people you know,
almost unanimously praising.
Yeah. He's amazing.
He's a very talented guy. I gotta check
it out, but it seems kind of dark.
I don't want them to bump me out.
Isn't it funny how that is now?
Have you seen ted? No, I haven't
heard anything. Hurts me.
Go in there and going there
expecting to laugh. Yeah, I'm sure.
Good laps. Well, I love Seth
Macfarlane. He's got a great attitude.
I liked that dude. I like listening to
him when he does interviews. I like,
I like his attitude, you know? I
met him once, he was super nice.
And what's the guy? The
Star? Marky Mark Wahlberg.
Wahlberg really can act well.
It's getting a little bit too
anal for me though. Any weird?
He's getting weird. Yeah. Where with
you? I didn't know he was talking about,
you know,
he was doing the movie and
he memorizes all his lines.
He comes prepared. Right.
You know what I mean? Like,
so when was, what was the
context of him saying this? Well,
he had a lot of dialogue,
the name and girls
and he could rattle it off, right.
Problem. Whereas most actors, you know,
and,
and he nailed the people who ran and go
to work told me an awesome story this
past weekend about John Claude van Damme
and an ordinary, I wouldn't tell it,
but it just seems like this
one you can get away with rent,
especially if Randy Randy would say that,
uh,
John Claude would come into set after
partying all night. I forget his,
and it would hold
his hands up like this, like this,
like to tell them to give him his line.
Apparently still partying. John Claude
van Damme, still going at it hard.
You got to love it. You know, showing up.
This set just hammered. That's his line.
Talking about what like Walberg all of
a sudden he's turned into those super
professional, perfect guy.
It's evolving. I Dunno.
Happier this way. Maybe. I Dunno. I
haven't felt him. He liked him in things.
He did a really, really, really good
job. Yeah. But I think he can't wait.
He's getting a little bit too
[inaudible] need to get them high.
Is that what you're saying? You want
to, you want to get Marky mark. Hi.
He said like his kids,
he'll never take his kids to see this ted,
you know,
can really cause it's too
graphic. Potty mouth, right?
I Dunno.
Is he trying to change as a or something?
Maybe it's his wife and his wife's
real conservative. Who knows?
Maybe it's trying to change his image.
Maybe it's just a, he's a businessman.
It's making the pitch.
Oh whoa.
Tommy Chong just insinuated that
Mark Walberg May in fact be a bitch.
I can't believe you just went there.
We need to get you high again.
You got whatever you smoked
before the show wore off. I like,
I like Ted on the teddy bear. Yeah, great.
Moving into the sequel is going
to be even a better one because
I think the next one's just going to,
as long as you keep the same director
because I think they'll think they'll find
more weird things for the teddy
bear to do. Yeah, totally.
And I can't wait to see it.
I can't wait. This is good.
And I'm looking forward to that. Mila.
Mila Kunis. So beautiful. Dot. Huh?
Well, I worked with her for years.
70 show. Oh yeah, that's right.
What's it like doing that
show? A connection now? Did
join it. I really enjoyed it.
It was, did anybody on that show or try
to convert you into Scientology? Uh,
not really. No, not really. No. I mean,
they have some medical things
I was hacking and coughing.
Scientology helped you with
say no. No. Danny. Danny.
He got me into the vitamin C Drip Habib
or does that is Danny Scientologists.
Yeah. And so is the Laura
Prepon, right? Yeah.
It's interesting how many actors are
Scientologists, doesn't it? Well,
it's like acting school, you
know, when you think about it,
it's the ultimate acting school. They
teach you how to act in public. Really.
Is that what it is and how to control
people. That's why the steer it.
But did you ever get involved in a little
bit on the type of teaching that we
had this, we had a series of managers
when we were coming up trying to make it,
this one guy,
we didn't know he was a Scientology until
he got us booked in this club or this
call in Hollywood
before we'd go on stage every time
she should have to go take a dump.
Teach comes back and he goes, this
is a weird place man. You know,
they got written on the walls there.
I
struggle was thrown into the
mail stream of the universe
instead of here. I sit
brokenhearted, right.
It's the mail stream of the universe and
all the Scientology bullshit. Bullshit.
Wow. While you're taking a dump. And
so, so we went on stage, you know, and,
and they're all staring at these stair,
they stare, they just stare into it.
And the Stepford wives, right.
They Kinda, they Kinda, I use,
I like to show or we worked
through a couple of times.
Wow. It was fun. Well listen man,
you gotta let us know when
the animated movie comes out.
So it will tweet the shit out of it.
[inaudible] us know when
your podcast comes out, so
it's going to call a podcast.
That's what your podcast,
you know there was already a podcast,
a podcast, but it doesn't matter. Right? I
used to be doing, there's always they do.
Yeah, he's still podcasts and just just
smoke. It wasn't what it was called.
It was called a podcast,
but a,
the girl I did it with was an actress
and she's like, you know what?
I need to say, probably,
maybe name it something else.
We call it a pop cast.
This is ruining my image,
being connected with something awesome
and I'm not comfortable with that.
It may limit me from lying
and bullshitting, which
I know some of them not.
Maybe makes them nervous. Listen, man,
you've been a hero to the marijuana
movement and the comedy movement and
everything for fucking decades. Man,
it's an honor to do a podcast with you.
When I was a little kid, listen to
those albums at my parents' house.
I had never would have imagined
that we'd be able to do this.
So thank you very much for doing this.
Did they tell you I got cancer? Yeah,
you did it. We went over there.
That's my new thing to ride on. No,
I'm going to write down your hook.
I'm going to write down cancer hooks.
A good hook. Yeah, it is. It ain't. I
love you how they can. Then I got to go.
See the guys might be going, so
you're going to be around for a while.
Eat unhealthy. Apparently. If I get the
right finger up my butt, I'll be okay.
I think we got that. If you need
help, Brian is a magic finger.
Show me magic fingerprint.
It shows over a creepy ending.
Thank you to a on it,
O, n n I t, makers of Alpha brain,
and now the new whole sport's fitness
aspect to it we have in the company and
with kettle bells and battle ropes
and protein powders coming soon,
and all the questions about
all the different supplements.
Go to [inaudible] dot com that's o
and n I t and use a code name Brogan.
You will get 10% off all supplements.
It doesn't count for a
weightlifting shit though,
cause it's the margins
on these are very low.
It's as cheap as we can possibly sell
them to send cannon balls through the
fucking mail. So go
that, go check that out.
And thanks to the fleshlight
go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the fleshlight.
Used the code name Brogan and save
yourself 15% often number one sex toy from
men.
And thanks to alien ware computers for
a constantly supporting mixed martial
lock. That's why we're
using them for this podcast.
Alienware's isn't even a sponsor of the
podcast. We just want to thank them.
Two different guys at this past UFC.
Uh, we're sponsored by alien, um,
a mega Madoff and I forget the other guy's
name. I think that I've got this, hey,
how you say the guy's name? Khabib, if
I had a crazy long ass Russian name,
he beat Gleason t bow. Great fighter.
But, um, and thanks to a Alienware on MMA,
go to alien ware, MMA on Twitter. Um,
it, yeah. Alienware MMA on Twitter.
Tommy Chong on Twitter,
red ban on Twitter.
I'm Joe Rogan and we'll see you
tomorrow with Kevin Pereira.
And then Wednesday we got Adam
coke cash from Adam versus the man.
And we also have a Wednesday
death squad show in the main room.
It's gonna be a super show. It's wanting
to be one of the bigger shows. And uh,
and then I was on it. Who's on it? I
can't tell you. It's a secret secret.
Is Joe Rogan going to be on it?
That's right. You dirty bitch.
I might actually also be at comicon
with us, right? Well, Friday,
Friday I tickets are on
sale@americancomedyco.com
or [inaudible]. Dot TV.
We're going to be there
Thursday and Friday.
I think Joe's just going
to be there Friday. Yeah,
just on Friday. I'll be
there Friday night. Uh,
I gotta check out this comic con thing.
See what the fuck is going down. Yeah.
All right, folks. We've got a
lot of, a lot of shows this week.
Love shows next week, and a lot of people,
I'm still trying to get on the hook.
Thanks for all the support and all
the cool vibes you send out there.
We appreciate it. We, we've, we love
you guys. As much as you love us,
we're not going anywhere.
We'll see you [inaudible] soon.
Okay.